[Music]
n
yeah yeah mike check what is going on
real Sunday Sunday the Lord's Day how
y'all doing out there it's do a little
roll call see how the levels are
sounding what's going on see some some
familiar faces already round get to the
front of the
congregation what's going on feeling a
little Good Feeling little good we got
some super chats already shout out the
Star Killer fin Super Chat factions was
broken through the ice and sank into the
abyss never to be seen again RP okay
star kill again with the bars remember
for eight months I wish the CMA would
approved the ABK acquisition October 9th
or 10th versus the end of next week 2023
has been a great year for Xbox yeah we
going to discuss we will discuss shout
out to Zach Riley in the building new
name I never seen this K the Kong No
Doubt salute Zack DB what's going on
salute
salute lyan Master what's going on talk
to me what's going on out here we got a
lot of people already getting in the
front you know what I'm saying pop do
what up scoty what's going all hindsight
with the hustle I like the new audio was
clear my man yeah yeah I had to turn the
um you know what is I had the the the
the the main beat too loud because I got
the new you know I'm on that NZXT the
new rig you know you get a new rig your
settings you got to change everything up
so that's what it was whatever I brought
over the settings a little too loud so I
had to turn me up turn my levels up turn
my mic up
S kti my mans oh what's going on Salute
to you bro salute to you I like um when
you sent me that drint with the with the
beat for the IOP and you do that was
dope I always appreciate that daddy
passion official you know what I'm
saying for all the frauds out there this
the official daddy passion y'all better
I love that [__] young dread what's up
the young artist what's going on Le fit
Lee Fitness okay catching us loud I like
the name Lee fit s very health as well
I'm about that chill my man father
Gucci I like that name father Gucci
what's going on Welcome to the
Real oh we got to talk all we got talk
about that Quest three yeah yeah yeah
pre-orders in no doubt n oh that's the
homie n Nate what's going on it's a
pleasure to meet you what was it um Pax
West talking at Nintendo you know what
I'm saying Dr Strange L I'll be watching
you you getting out of
pocket I've been watching you you
getting you you trying to battle um play
with your joystick for the title I see
what you're doing out there head casti
is going on salute salute salute you
already know yeah we got some fun we got
some fun today you know some surprise is
you know what I mean so yeah looking
forward they got a nice a bunch of nice
topics so I am excited to see what is
going on Jackson Jacob was going on
salute salute so we going to try to get
everybody in the realm maybe a little
like I said a little surprise let's
let's see what's going on and um hold on
yeah I know you all about that strange
lover you got to
relax James Morrison what up but anyway
so look we going to get back to you fun
show I got to make sure everybody is all
right and uh yeah man give get these d
bars right quick until we get back
father Gucci with the be oh yeah yeah
yeah yo that's coming soon we got one
more week for that I know the realm has
been demanding Lord beefy I know I know
it's coming it's coming it's coming he
putting finishing touches on that
appreciate that and uh we gave y that
what you call last week we gave you that
corporate car you know what I'm saying
but we got to give you that beefy it's
coming soon trust me I see I'm seeing
the final Vision you know what I'm
saying No Doubt young dress appreciate
you for the inspiration we like I said
we got some make some little changes
here and there but yo but what you got
cooking oh yeah what the health is well
we going to talk but anyway okay Danny
pass official $2 Super Chat Danny
officially retired Jim flying Ryan oh
man anyway I'm going let y'all go we got
to get the rest of the loads up in here
and I will talk to you
soon here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mine go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and make it INF flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's Saron up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I be running
collecting the range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on a you check my
vocals TT but I'm anal love my city but
I'm still Co I
got don't stop that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoiled feeling to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't here the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making vult Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber because it's pretty hard to sleep
on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that again
here you here you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started I am well it's not
important who I am um what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sarson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rigns you just a Target
when I'm in the rain I was the hardest
to start regardless back when was Ming
people a check my vocs Twitter but I'm
anal love my city but I'm still by Co I
got's what you do don't stop that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil them to be your
dog they very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you you
ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougar and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer that's woo let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertain until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Aron up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the BL
still I'll be running collecting R you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest start regardless back
when you was messaging people on a check
my voal Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I
got
you that was doe keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going go ahead
look I guess you can say that I'm very
spoal feel to be your dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you ain't got to say
it I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the r you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on a check my vocals all on Twitter but
I'm antisocial love my city but I'm
still coal I got now
let's what you do don't stop that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you can say that I'm very spoil feel
them to be your dog they very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a never
been a loser making Vault Tron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y' messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be hanni they
be like why use a video game just be
original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flamable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they they can Saron up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting a
r you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when was messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti love my city but
I'm still I
[Music]
got going keep that going n Go ahead
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil feel them to be your dogs they
very loyal but I ain't going to told you
I ain't heard the boy you you ain't got
to say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy krer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all Dramatical I know it's
random but I am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
that this is that Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's aring up in your apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a check my vocal all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still coal I got let's
Swit you don't stop n that was dope keep
that keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead I guess could say that
I'm very spoil feel them to be your dog
they a't very loyal but I ain't going to
hold you I ain't heard the boy you ain't
got to say it I'm embarrassed for you
always been a nerd never been a loser
making Vault trying with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is De Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them RS you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on AIM check my vocals all on Twitter
but I'm antisocial love my city but I'm
still by coal I got let's Swit that you
do
St keep that keep that going keep that
going no go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoil feel them to be
your dog they very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we about get started I am well it's
not important who I am um what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a canable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's aring up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still by coal I got
let's switch up um what did you do Don't
Stop N that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going n Go
ahead look I guess you can say that I'm
very spoiled feel to be dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
vult Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rign you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on a check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by a coastal I got
let's switch that what did you do don't
stop that was dope keep keep that keep
that going keep that going go ahead look
I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil feel them to be your dog they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
Vault Tron with a gang of cougars and
I'm going places better tell a uber cuz
it's pretty hard to sleep on Freddy
kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lord's podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being being accountable and
they say I'm better than money because
you can Bank on me being accountable I
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable I kill a beat and they
want to compare me to Freddy and Jason I
rather be Hannibal they be like why use
a video game just be original y'all to
Dramatical I know it's random but I
addicted to flipping the sample and
making INF flammable this is that this
is that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Aron up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still I
be running colleting the range you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you was messaging people on AIM check
mycs but I'm anal love my but I'm I
got Stop N that was dope keep that keep
that keep that going keep that going n
Go ahead look I guess you can say that
I'm very spoil to be your dog thing very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you you ain't got to
say it I'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making V
Tron with a gang of cougars and I'm
going places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a canable and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arsing up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm antisocial love
my city but I'm still by coal I
gotch what did you do don't stop that
was dope keep that keep that keep that
going keep that going n Go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very spoil
feel them to be your dog they very loyal
but I ain't going to hold you I ain't
heard the boy you ain't got to say it
I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser makeing Vault
Tron with a gang of cougar and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's
let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am U
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up in turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that yog this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest of started
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM got check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got's Swit what
you do stop that was keep that keep that
going keep that going go ahead look I
guess you could say that I'm very SPO to
be your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better till
a Uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y to messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
and
[Music]
Snapp oh
yro call Proclaim both loud and clear a
proclamation of
invation not on
me I cry the prises of
theal near the river St lawence with the
St
[Music]
through I'mma just chill and watch them
snacks in the attic I wanted to with a
pack and be like a young Whooper then
they will mistake me for addict if I can
imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give her that
option you going to be single player
like siren you going to get tossed in
the bushes by King David royalty and not
a pretender detrimental to a Elemental
what a avatar to a knee Bender I got to
be me I know it's my destiny work too
who cares if you fly if you still a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be steo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that dude can't
never still be the can't get a statu
since a juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
that is cool and it's beautiful we let
you know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a Sunday is suitable
cuz you can listen to this in your
cubicle on the Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday aable
cuz you can listen to this in your
cubicle on a Lord's
day oh yeah
yeah yeah
we going Mike's are hot we going to do
mic check with you right quick so talk
to us right quick hola
hola d adct right quick what's going on
what's going on guys yeah yeah yeah no
doubt we going to get this thing going
here you hear
you and welcome to the IR Lords podcast
we are live and are live on actually on
Lords of gaming.net episode number 325
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's day and
today we've got Last of Us factions on
Ice Xbox and ABK deal soon
potentially I miss Kings laugh right now
cuz I I'm used to always getting
interrupted come on let me interject let
me you got to do the Ki you got did K
Assassin's Creed
Mirage yeah Forza
Motorsport yeah and red Fall's latest
update to
discuss yeah he gonna get you the wo
with that one so we G to get right into
it so let's
introduce so let's introduce the four I
think we're missing one Horseman what is
what is going on we all missing one
Horseman all jokes inside you know our
brother kig you know what I'm saying you
know we we may see him we may not see
him send him some love send some love
send kig some love you know what I'm
saying right now she's got some things
going on but uh you never know you never
know what might what might happen you
know what I'm saying in the realm today
so I I I'm just want to be very uh
transparent we do have someone coming
through put in the chat who you guys
think it is because I I'm on curious if
anyone
guesses guesses them no
doubt so let's introduce those other
horsemen of the realm original gaming
night real he said King is a lock up the
other
the other the Jackson
four Tito J Tito
J and the rest of the and the rest of
the dudes my coost with the coost my
brother with another mother the
difficult game conquerer Lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man Lord addict back to back of the
addict show how we doing sir doing
pretty good uh first thing I want to
bring up is uh you know shout out to hex
gaming you know I played this for
a couple about two weeks now if it would
actually like there we go yeah there we
go so this is the they sent this time
they sent us the PlayStation
version you know it's I actually made
this with my girl like I kind of like
that it's kind of crispy the little BL
with the joy little accents on the side
you know what I'm saying yeah I'm
feeling that so like the build quality
of this thing like is like solid like it
really is like I now obviously I've had
to force myself to play on the
PlayStation a little bit more than I
normally do why you had to force himself
I don't really like until Spider-Man
comes I don't really got nothing to play
over there CU I play all like multiplats
and stuff on Xbox and PC and you know
what I like about this is like it's got
these I I've never had like
a it's got these little it's actually
it's blurring it if you go still blur if
you going too close yeah yeah back yes
what's that oh the paddles in the back
right yeah these are these are four
buttons there's one there's two here on
the center yeah oh so it's almost like
it's like the the elite it's like an
elite controller yeah that's F I would
actually compare this to um The Edge
controller than than like a red a
standard a standard uh dual uh sense
controller what what I like is like just
how customizable you know look at the
got the the white the white Chrome thing
that was my girl she you know she she
had this thing looking different we we
had to like compromise got the the
texture I love these texture things oh
the grips yeah yeah yeah the grips is
hard I like that yeah I can't do an Xbox
controller now without these things yeah
those grips is important yeah I I I will
agree with King when it comes to the
packaging it's like man you guys got to
step up that packaging like that
packaging is is is not it it's not it's
and I don't know like logistic
wise how hard it is to make a packaging
you know like a lot of Premium
controllers like it like the You Do The
Flap one you lift it up and the
controllers just sitting there they
don't really have that system for this
and it's just like you know for for the
amount of you know costly this
controller could be it's like that's the
number one feedback I can
give go go back to the drawing board
when it comes to how you present this
because that look at the end of the day
is that mad important no but that can
leave a a like a really especially when
you're doing unboxing videos like the
way that the controllers presented to
you can can kill a whole unboxing video
and it's just like that is the first
thing that these people are going to see
when they look into it this is not made
by Sony so shady so let's Cal down Shady
was quick shady is quick on the trigger
yeah so hex gaving got the little the
the blue flames I don't know if people
see if that's Flames or not
mhm it's it's my head that it keeps they
saw it the first time you put it up like
three
times so I enjoy you know shout out to
them uh for uh sending that over and I I
think you know I I'm I'm slowly trying
to to get to work with one of these
companies I want IP controlls oh
okay controller that CR I want to put
our logo on a controller think I think
that would be a
real solid experience and then obviously
may maybe maybe have one of the um
because the the the the Xbox is right
here the the little wraps why if we got
a wrap like not be tough yeah it's just
I'm sure some of these companies make
their companies reach
out at boy we got you reach out holl at
the wolf he ready he ready to work yeah
but you know shout out to hex gaming
very solid controller really enjoy
playing it and you know it gives me
actually something to look forward to
when I do play on that PlayStation that
you know I I actually have the the
regular duel since controller here yeah
that that new that hex Jo look tough I
ain't going to front whatever you been
playing
sir uh Assassin's Creed
marage I also been playing the what's
that game called
infinity infinity trash Infinity trash
that that Infinity trash Dragon Quest
The Adventures of Kai it's it's it's a
pretty nice little experience it's
there's so much stuff going on right now
I haven't really had time to like lock
down on any particular uh you know game
you know shout out to that game that
game's been pretty solid I've been
playing that been playing Assassin's
Creed Mirage I've been playing um you
know I'm I'm looking for the Lords of
the Fallen that should be coming here
soon yeah yeah it's tough we got a
chance I'm kind of glad that hasn't got
here but at the same time it's like I
like to get you know a few hours in that
game and then you know obviously
Spider-Man I think by the oh yeah like a
week and a half we'll be into Spider-Man
well that's that's next Friday you know
that's a Friday after net yeah uh so the
22nd is the
Spiderman podcast that that's going to
be interesting yeah and real quick
before I pass it on to S can someone
please help me find a poster for
Spider-Man I can't find one anywhere
it's like PlayStation doesn't sell
Spiderman man two posters and I don't
understand do they have do Spider-Man
one you see anyone from the first one
they have Spider-Man one but it's just
like to me I could get that but it's
like why don't you have a Spider-Man 2
poster for the game that's literally
about to come out maybe Walmart doesn't
have it Amazon doesn't have
one I couldn't find it anywhere I wanted
one I thought the best poster you could
have possibly got is venom in the middle
and Peter on one side and miles on the
other like just like they've been
showing it everywhere but I can't find
one someone hit me up on Twitter yeah
let us know what's going on he said we
got you at it you already know and of
course we have the most technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sof stradamus the Lord of
clarity and Lord patreon of the iron
bank PC Master races own Lord Sovereign
how we doing sir I am good coming in hot
today apologies no
coming in h but I'm
good good overall uh good overall uh
feeling a little bit better coughing
less good but not completely gone but
still uh yeah so and that's that uh
gaming wise my life hates me so are you
not putting out floods you're not you
know well yeah exactly that's kind of
been the residuals of that has been like
the rest of the week and then just like
not being able to sit down and game but
I did what I did do I played a little
bit of of AC Mirage old school
Assassin's Creed you know I'm in
Assassin's Creed like I know we going
talk about that I'm a fiend so I played
that on uh I actually just put it on the
the PC this morning and O how we looking
how we looking on that ncxt what's going
on show me the build uh Ultra all the
way through Ultra what we doing how we
what's the stats with the specs the the
specs you want specs to the machine or
the specs of the game what I'm just
being
stupid you run that game on Ultra all I
was I was asked by you know the person
that made all all the NZXT thing
possible they're like how'd that Foria
run I was like like a
dream it kind of makes want to play more
games on PC because I like know that
anything I play isn't gonna have you
know obviously unless I'm being strong
armed by S you know I'm trying my best
for them not to play the inferior
versions on purpose I don't understand
this I'm going to purposely pick the
inferior
version when I have the op see if you
didn't have the option it'd be different
right like I'm not going to I'm not
going to shame you for that you have the
option nah I'll go over here why why we
can't enjoy our console sensibility
sometimes we gota we got to take it to
the max you got to take it to why you
you have the option to do better why
it's adct that be resistant I I'll be
I'll be going over there I'll be I'll be
I'll be firing it up you know what I'm
saying don't go over there I'll be on
that block I'll be on that block some
time yeah I got to be
I'm the only thing Cog be doing on that
PC he be do on the block of PC's Drive
By is that's all listen man speaking of
that rock yes yes it runs beautifully on
that rock that Mirage runs very very
nice on that rock yes very nice so yeah
we'll talk about it more as again I
don't have a lot of time with it but
enough to kind of glean certain old
school things that I that I'm seeing and
you know so we'll talk about that no
down and of course obviously we missing
one Lord the king but uh you know stick
around we may may see him you never know
you know you might see him later we see
but set some love to the king no no no
and King he'll he'll pop in on like the
the Jim Ryan conversation and just and
just join in progress I know you guys
ain't letting this I'm pretty confident
King is going to let us know you know
what I'm saying if we we not keeping it
all the way or with certain situations
you know what I'm saying but of course
we got and if he doesn't get us this
he'll get us next exactly oh you know
then we going get you know what it is
and we going to get the call like yo I
listen and then I can't believe
y'all we get this strong discipline even
adct not even adct was with me on this
like yeah what you say you maybe if we
get 200 likes so you know show up in
some way we might have to see that 200
like you know people always be like how
you going to lock King behind a pay off
because I work with the tools I have I
agree I mean I mean I think a couple of
likes would be you know real nice to
free that would be amazing that would be
amazing I I I mean if y'all really want
to see him y'all call user Jackson 4 and
all
that not even just the Jackson the Jack
yo that's
worse there's no no
individualization yeah that's that's
that's the equivalent of them dudes like
n we not yo you know what's funny like I
see people be like oh you know what
addict acted like this is this is like a
battle pass yeah and I need those likes
on that battle pass it don't like it
cost you any money we don't feel
appreciated 450 people in here let's see
where the 200 likes is fair to get that
King opinion that ain't even enough
likes I feel you know what I'm saying
like they they need to stay with us
longer we got to we got to initiate this
battle pass further down the
track they right now that's too early in
the track we got to give we give him a
skin we give him skar that 200 but he
got to give him like 3 400 that I feel
no comfortable that they that I'm
feeling the love we
deserve then y'all can get kid that let
me hold got to hold it behind we put
King behind a pay wall and then y'all
want y'all want let
me and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself this [__] be even extra we
we only give him like 10% of the video
oh that's dirty that's dirty
exactly the shovi Lord kago spread that
real to the r in IOP not tell you what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear shout out to Mr Manny play Shout
out to fining Duke had a good one up
there talking about uh Xbox news and we
did our um Fantasy Draft um but you know
I actually smoked the boy last year had
had to get him you know what I'm saying
had to get him last year he what he
learned from his mistakes he ain't going
to do these ridiculous pcks where games
Pie in the Sky Xbox you know3 dreams you
know what happens when you go with your
heart exactly you go with your heart
things happen you know what I'm saying
but um yeah salute to him we got that
that should be up on on now that in the
uh we got an ultimate the fin ultimate
coming up with the fantasy draft part
two what we talk about for 2024 so
that's stay tuned for that shout out to
the last word bontis Tai guy Travis
really had a fun week talking about uh
the conclusion of Season of the Witch
they ended real good and obviously all
the bunge
controversies solve I think you'd find
that quite interesting the tweets on the
Latin community and and other things
that has happened yes I saw this once
again just just just you know I hate to
be the one to be like just shut up and
dribble like shut
up so just just keep it keep that out of
the game
room and then especially when I don't
want if I get into it yeah somebody
might be mad
listen but your opinion is definitely
respected you know what I'm saying and
um needed also on that because we we
talk his best as we could you know what
I'm saying consider we'll talk about it
cuz I I have feelings on on all of that
stuff um again I might piss somebody off
no you got tell you what he got oh shout
hold on shout out to one away Dragon TV
in the building back home fresh out the
hospital brother it's good to see you
moving and shaking he had the uh the
little video I'm alive bro it's good to
see him glad you're okay as a person who
is frequent in hospitals uh twice this
year um it's always good you know what
I'm saying to see you get get get
through that and your health is wealth
you know what I'm saying brother it was
good to see you in in your spirits and
then uh for me what else has been
obviously AC barage but rocking that oh
shout out to lamp lighters League um
gave yeah gave that a fire up you know
Lord turn base got to see what's going
on there um I will say at first I was
like I don't know I it started off
because again I'm coming in with
traditional term-based sensibilities and
this thing is like you're just kind of
like walking around in real time at
first and you can kind of search things
and and then they all have like these
individual abilities where you could
kind of sneak up on guards in real time
and but it was like they're limited
right and then it was the the other
chick was like a Bruiser it's like an
alternate
1930s um kind of universe spy kind of
energy so at first I'm like all right
this ain't turnbas you know what I'm
saying so I'm playing so as you use that
and you move through the stage it's not
like like a turnbas game you have a
stage and then you beat it you go to
another layer and then you go to another
you know whatever this is kind of like
yeah someone said it bit MMO it's a
hybrid so what happens is then you do
all your real time abilities that you
could do and eventually you going to
have to fight is guards it's Patrol you
going to have to fight that then you
initiate the turnbas moment with the
right trigger I believe I've played
games like that before I've never really
played a hybrid like that so um there's
one I can't remember what it was called
I'm sure someone in the uh the chat can
uh tell me it's like you played as like
mutant animals oh I remember that one
yes yes yes yes yes I know it's the one
with the duck on it right yeah yeah I
know what you're talking about adct I
know what you're talking about I'm
trying I know I reviewed it so keep
talking and I'll get yeah so pretty much
somebody said wastelanders in there oh
no not they retracted it but um so
anyway so as I'm playing then you ENT to
the ter base then it's the traditional
zero M year zero yes so then it's the
traditional sensibilities so I'm like
okay okay this is what I'm talking about
yo the spa dude I think his name was
Latif he's ill he he got a thing where
he could put a decoy move around the rap
then I like that he he he could sneak on
people and their Corner vision is lower
because he's a sneak I like the other
chick she's got brute stuff you get
people as you go through the game and
you kind of like rescue them and stuff
like that then the strategy L yo I ain't
going to front very ve I really like it
it it start to get better and better
they start introducing more mechanics
and more things you could do and and I
ain't going to for there is a difficulty
Spike that gets a little crazy but yeah
lampl is lead give it a shot man it's in
Game Pass I believe yeah I recommend you
try out mut your zero that game was good
it's got a difficult Spike too I
remember one time I was sitting there
and like all these people showed up I'm
like they know I only got three people
right yeah it get a little crazy but
like the the the some people have some
classic stuff like OverWatch there's a
there's a dude that's kind of like a um
lockpick guy but he he's good with the
guns he got the double you know shotgun
I mean the double um shooting kind of
mechanic it's really good like I I
really appreciate you know what they've
done so far story is okay but I has a
lot of good uh voice in it and I I got
shout out to them so yeah man give it a
shot lamp lighters league if if you're
thinking it and um yeah other than that
I've been rocking um still been playing
on Starfield Still rocking that and a
lot of Destiny for sou playing got got
back and the story is really good with
All Season of the Witch and been raiding
with the homie so that's been pretty
much it so if you want to get the super
chats and then I gotta take care of some
BS yeah hold on one second let me go get
this and funding okay we got Lord star
kellerer Xbox series x01 $5 Super Chat
factions is broke into the ice and sank
into the abyss J never to be seen again
rest in peace we we don't know that
but yeah it feels like you want to will
that into
existence then we got Lord Star Killer
again M for eight mons Lord bronze I
wish to CMA would approve the ABK
acquisition on October 9th to 10th
versus the end of next week 2023 has
been a great year for Xbox it's got to
be Friday the
13th i' be interested if it go down on
that day then we got Danny passion
official $2 Super Chat Danny officially
retired Jim flying
Ryan somebody did see let see what
happen when the news come out then we
have BT Maverick 707 $10 Super Chat any
of my r Ali gang deckheads pre-order the
Lenovo Legion go uh I'm looking forward
to seeing the reviews and capabilities
hopefully window side is easier to
navigate with the track pads thank you
ILP that's you right I have not Fallen
to the fomo again my my thing was this
if it was a faster CPU yes it's the same
CPU get a Z1 extreme right do Z1 extreme
now it does have faster Ram right I
don't know to what extent but the RAM is
faster it has bigger screen it has the
trackpads it has the removable sort of
joy-con like yeah like the switch joy
that that convert also to like a mouse
and trackpad pretty much right it it
does all of that so it's very cool stuff
I'm like if I'm not seeing a substantial
leap in performance I'm I'm good for
right now I'm good for right now this is
interesting though this very very cool
what they're doing with it very
interesting I want to see how they
interfaces but I'm hearing no vrr for
them unlike to be vrr HDR it has HDR HDR
but the Ally doesn't have HDR for say oh
no I'm no no HDR right but I was talk
correct me before I think I heard it
from jez no vrr on on it but yeah
confirm if you can maybe maybe I got it
wrong or maybe he got it wrong but I
could have sworn I heard that from him
listen to him recently I'll finish the
Super Chat I'll look into it yeah no
doubt no doubt but uh I could have SW it
had it though I know it has a a faster
refresh rate if I'm not mistaken on the
screen might be might be 144 Herz or
something like that craziness that's
crazy that's crazy
okay okay okay then we have rambling
entertained five Super
Chat I'm playing Horizon zero Dawn and I
found it to I found it to have great
gameplay but why did no one call Out
PlayStation or gorilla when they said
this game is an
RPG it is it's an action RPG that like
you have upgrade paths and stuff like
that that make it RPG like um so it's
very much an open world kind of action
RPG it's not just a straight action game
but I again it it's just it's going to
depend on how because you don't have to
do all of that stuff right right you
could beine the story not really care
too much about the open world not really
care too much about upgrading your
weapons and stuff like that and you know
it'll be more of an action game but it
it can be played as both I would say
fair enough fair enough and we got
doctor strange love5 super chat here we
go H I heard you don't like mayil on
your hot dog but what if I gave a nice
load of my organic homemade meil on your
meat would that change your mind yo we
need King here cuz I need to beat yeah
we need to beat he's the only one to get
the beat work properly yo King Got the
Beat uh King you all missed right
now back to
you
woo and let's put the crest in the chat
for Lord bronze NC ghost of low road
thank you brother appreciate you yes
salute salute L then we have Robert
kellet $5 Super Chat can't wait for the
Last of Us Part Two remastered on PS5
Last of Us fractions Last of Us golfing
for psvr2 and Last of Us two remake on
PS ps6 messy messy then we have
Necromancer Zale member for 22 months
Lord gold Kalisto protocol Dead Space
remake and soon Allan Wake It's Been a
Good Year of horror games yes I'm
excited for Alan Wake 2 my lord it's a
big one it's a big one
then we got Robert kellet $2 Super Chat
oh no the joystick steal King
away no I'm not even going to say that
he be pissed yeah I I had yeah I was
going to say something funny but he
going watch it
yeah I'm
good yeah then we have tsws gaming
member for six months Lord gold physical
collector's edition of Dead Island 2 is
$25 with the expansion pass at GameStop
website uh shout out that's crazy Force
spoken is 1750 physical and
more some deals looking for them deal
end of year deals they're here for sure
they're starting to get here anyway
facts get them deals together then we
got Doctor Strange Love again5 Super
Chat Cog I need you to give Bungie the
smoke first they take away my last of us
factions then they call me and my people
latinx give them that MK1
Smoke listen man uh I I will give you
that like yeah it's been a rough rough
week them you know PR wise um obviously
that tweet was not well received and you
know the community spoke back out that
and um Talk That Talk
s let's give s his bars I rather s just
get his bars off now because it's it's
the timing I feel is right if you want
to can you set it up for me please well
yeah well pretty much you know obviously
it was a a big tweet by by Bungie let
see if I can pull it up in in reference
to um the Latin community and it
definitely got a lot of push back trying
to get the exact quote on it for a
second right now give me a second here
cuz H this is professional podcasting
this is what we do let's get that join
CU they actually I don't think they even
took it down which is kind of
interesting no I I didn't expect them to
to be honest with you I thought they
just kind of think off I kind of thought
they would so here it is all right so um
basically this is October 2nd U being
Latin
eox is more than just the location on
the map just as being Hispanic is more
than the language we speak we are proud
to introduce our new idea Latin at
Bungie so yeah this got a lot of um
almost what is it 23 million impressions
on Twitter the responses have been less
than Pleasant um looks like uh Twitter
or X should we call it now they've added
some additional um verbiage to the
context to it saying that others note is
that this tweet is almost correct not
even descendants of Latino migrants in
the USA like Latin X or Latin e Latin
people or Latin person would be correct
Latin X or Latin e are Suggestions by
people who don't understand Latin
languages or foreign culture so that was
the context added to the Tweet by
Twitter So Sol uh our resident uh should
we what we going to call you our token
Latino our resident Latino on the
scene coming to you live from I don't
feel qualified yeah coming to you live
I don't feel qualified to answer because
obviously I am not part of the affected
group but I definitely understand you
know wanting to be represented and also
you know not you know if you're not
feeling something that another group or
whatever is you know saying about your
group so I'm done rambling what are your
thoughts on this I mean I'm all for the
idea
of having to still well okay let's do
this it saddens me that we are still at
a point in in in the history of humanity
that we have to set aside dates and
times to celebrate specific cultures
whether it be you know Black Culture
whether it be Latin culture because in
day-to-day life they're underrepresented
right it bothers me that there's a Black
History Month it bothers me that there's
a Latin Heritage Month it should just be
you know what it just be the the the
heritage of of of humanity it's all
mixed in right I get you I get you it
bothers me that that has to be the
case with all that said when it comes to
the idea of being La Latin Latino Latina
Hispanic my troubles with attaching the
ex to it and sort of the ex being
representative of everything of
everything and everyone is that there's
really no need for it because the word
Latin on its own does not indicate a
gender The L Word Hispanic on its own
does not indicate gender you can you can
say I'm Latin I'm hispan or I'm Hispanic
and it still be as broad as saying
something like a Latin X so I I don't it
kind of feels like that's a new
generation thing that when you think
about it a lot of people talk about it
stand on soap boxes about it kind of in
social media circles but I I I haven't
met anybody who kind of ask you like I
want to be I want to be referred to as
that um I work with a number of people
who are who are are queer transgender a
number of people and none of them you
know none of them
so take one okay no when it when it
comes to when it comes to their Heritage
no obviously some some of them they
prefer like you know they them pronouns
and things of that nature but when it
comes to Heritage that the latinx thing
is not something that they sort of
gravitate to it it it's kind of not a
real thing um again because we have we
have a way to to identify ourselves that
way if that's what we choose right in
the same way you know I would identify
myself as a Hispanic man or a Latino um
you know so that that's the thing and to
me that's again people standing on soap
boxes and what what bothers me a lot
about that is that sometimes I I feel
that it's it's not the people that are
actually affected by it it's the people
that think that they have something to
pay you know you heard the thing of like
you know White Man's Burden like this
thing that I okay okay I carry this
guilt for for things that have happened
in the past and and and it's sometimes
it's those people trying kind of
overstepping bounds and not
understanding that sometimes these type
of movements are best left to the people
that are affected by it as opposed to
you trying to uh sort of O overtly be
helpful and and I understand none of it
is in Malice at all but it sometimes in
doing that you're not really
understanding the point of it so when
you
say again so so I I don't think what
Bungie was is intending to do here is
necessarily off base it's in its overall
intention it's just that when
you you're showing that you have one
point of view on it right and and that
point of view is something that is in my
in my opinion and in in my uh sort of
experience till now it's just something
that's sort of expressed in social media
sort of discussions on this sort of
stuff and not something that presents
itself in real life so that that to me
is what bothers me um again we already
have a way to identify ourselves if we
want to remove gender from the equation
or or kind of leave it you know so so
that's the way I feel about it and again
I might piss somebody off by saying that
but the the X thing to me just feels
like it's yeah it's it's again it's
another thing to this effect is and it
goes back to my original point it's just
like these are the things that continue
to create divisions and we don't see
that as opposed to just
as opposed to
just learning how to accept each other's
differences in a world where now it's
you know you have to you have to really
pay attention if you haven't been
someone who who's never paid attention
to that who's never been around people
who who questioned hey you know this
might be offensive if you say this to me
in this way or that way that way there
are ways to address that that don't
continue to create divides between us
right and and the X thing to be honest
with you I just kind of think it it
continue it creates another divide as
opposed to us just learning as human
beings to deal with one another it's
it's it's very simple if you think about
it we just tend to complicate things no
no respect I respect what you said and
you know I see a lot of you know
consensus on that I believe Chris Ragan
had similar comments and thoughts to you
in reference to that and you know some
people feel oh Chris spoke on it yeah
Chris spoke on it Chris spoke on it and
you know I would highly recommend listen
to the latest sacred in reference to his
comments on that and um yeah some people
feel it's a imposing or hijacking langu
all I will say this in reference to get
back to the gaming I know was like we're
going to get to the gaming which is um
you know as far as Bungie this is what I
will say you know it's person that
obviously I'm a fan of Bungie I've known
him for a long time obviously I play
their games I think that internally my
thought process is that they try to
cater to everyone they are very diverse
inclusive kind of thing and sometimes
you may have a smaller subgroup that
maybe they were try to represent cuz I
thought interested the Tweet didn't go
down that was my whole thing and I think
now this could be a teaching moment that
obviously the group affected does not
like this right so you know hopefully
they learn from it but I'm glad I did
want to talk about it CU it was so big
and I was like damn I haven't talked to
you so sorry Chad I be talking to my
brother and just getting his feeling on
it but that that's what I want to get
but we can get back to the Super Chat in
the game yeah again it's a crude way of
saying just just focus on what you do yo
you stupid just do what you do just do
what you do man do what you do again
feel how you want to feel just don't
include it in everything you do like
just you know give me a a a nice well
represented Latino character whatever
game you know what I mean like but you
know what I mean like research it make
sure the voice is right the timber of
the voice is right the again and in in a
in a world like a destiny like what does
that even mean right again but that that
is specifically why you could just do
kind of whatever you want in those
scenarios where it's a fantasy world but
fa so he can't have a Boda in the tower
okay I I I would say not do that we
can't B in we can't the coochie
Freo no chop cheese in the tower we
can't have chop cheese in the tower oh
man all right you know what I would not
you know me I'm not offended by I be
like that's
hilarious X in the tower everybody else
like burning
down burning Stak the bung headquarters
get
that I you in the tower let's go anyway
up I wouldn't be opposed to it but you
know you know the world we live world
that we live
in fair enough what else we got on the
super
CH stereotypes are 99% true anyway most
of the time we gonna get cancel Time
move it know know oh let me see let me
see let me
see uh Robert Kell do L Super Chat King
Early Access King Early Access DLC
question mark I bumping prices F yeah
let's see what the likes are we free
kick where the likes at yeah where them
likes at oh they at 220 they at 220 they
almost theread they at 300 they almost
there the ratio will be halfway yeah we
going to hold them behind the pay wall y
y ain't farther enough on the battle
pass yet moving
on we got sin Vendetta $10 Super Chat
you should partner with Pope art for IOP
controller yeah Pope artist fam so you
know you never know never know never
know you never know and we got
Necromancer Zale $5 Super Chat corpo Cog
no bungee monetization models here on IL
please n n corporate Cog is here let's
see what the legs is at let corporate we
at 220 that's not 247 all right we get
there it's an easy battle pass not
asking much of you here listen man we
need more engagement corporate Cog needs
more engagement for IOP right now so
yeah we got to get 300 we get 300 I'll
get add to release that but right now we
need y'all further on the battle pass
continue then we got Necromancer A5
Super Chat Sony needs to be investigated
for an anime distribution Monopoly in
the US after the crunchy roll and Right
Stuff
merger yeah then we got we got Gerald
Mack remember the 35 mons Lord silver is
it safe to say that the P that became a
snowball is now become an avalanche game
pass Xbox World Order is fully
operational oh I mean y know I'm the one
that came up with the a
yeah we got to see what's going to
happen they got a lot of things cooking
man lot of things then we got
Necromancer $2 Super Chat meant to add
that they're closing down right stuff oh
they are shutting they're merging and
closing down right stuff as an
individual thing okay okay addict any
any thoughts on this addict is in the
bushes for some reason okay okay we look
to you uh we're done we're caught up all
right no doubt so let's take care of the
bills and other things was going on and
uh yeah log that time long that time of
the month you already know what it is
shout out to Lords of gaming.net our
amazing writing team amazing editorial
team competition every month is very
good and uh some of the best in the game
man so yeah we got to celebrate one
particular scribe at Lords gaming.net
and went Above and Beyond in the month
of September has been on absolute tear
and S give us live well not live but on
the floor coverage at the Tokyo game
show that is something I am extremely
extremely proud of of you know this is
one of our veterans you know what I'm
saying one of our our day one so to
speak has been doing it for a long time
probably present the latest winner of
the Lord dizzy scribe of the month to
the magic man the man with the the
beautiful soup Blazers Lord Jean sha
meire you know what I mean he couldn't
make it today obviously he couldn't get
a video in time but we wanted to give
him his flowers he absolutely killed it
highly advise you to go to Lords of.net
check out all his content he is a beast
to Tokyo on his own on his own di bro to
do this uh amazing yeah absolutely and
uh Lord jeene we are going to hopefully
join you in the future hopefully things
you know work out definitely um you know
brother that's one of our kind of bucket
listing that we got to get done and you
are the Lord of Tokyo so hey you got our
we got our L log that brother there that
would be dope to get that popping so
that's that and then our secondary log
that award in honor of my brother Lord
DIY as a nure of T this is the people
behind the scenes that don't get the
credit the editorial team that really
has been doing it for a long time this
is another one of our veterans for the
very beginning actually a first round
draft pick from Lord DIY himself um he's
the pillar of consistency he's been
killing he always comes up with great
ideas for the team how we can improve
his um cyber Punk uh Phantom Liberty
review was excellent he's informative
and then he's been killing it with the
news and guides on lies of peak he's
been really killing it with that and his
amazing walkthroughs and stuff like that
so we proudly present the winner of the
Lord Disney lognet editor of the month
to Lord Gondor AKA Daniel May so I think
he's got a little thing to say for us
hey guys I just want to start by
thanking everyone uh for honoring me as
editor of the month it is a fantastic
honor to get uh it is been such a great
time working and writing with Lords of
gaming I especially do want to shout out
the editor table and all the writers at
Lords of gaming I especially want to
shout out uh Cog as well as our editor
and chief mmud uh both of them
especially helped uh helped us get uh
the review coach for cyberpunk lies of
PE and has truly made the majority of my
gaming schedule this past month
additionally I also want to thank uh
anyone who I've got the chance to talk
to about Starfield the past month uh I
am really happy that a lot of people
resonated and saved uh the how to build
your ship guide I wrote at the beginning
of the month and I'm really happy to see
how well it's uh landed pun intended for
everyone uh I also especially do want to
thank anyone that I've got the chance to
talk to you about lies of PE uh it's
been great having a game that we've so
strongly talked about and have talked
about our various successes and failures
in that game uh and it's been a lot of
uh cool conversations around particular
games uh I am really for looking forward
to what we have coming up for Lords of
gaming and I just asked to all you
watching right now stay tuned we got a
lot of cool stuff
coming right salute salute L Gondor
editor of the month that is the homie
appreciate you what you do man like high
high quality work he's been killing it
for a long time so salute to him make
sure yall hit Sal up for your rewards
you know what I'm saying make sure y do
what y got to do and uh so we got um if
we I got patreon questions before we
jump into the topics or you want me to
you got super chat we got one more Super
Chat from Mandingo MC Thicket $2 Super
Chat I want a mandingo character
bulging whoa whoa
whoa doing the most you're doing the
most too much too
much I want you guys to put in the chat
you know I'm about to send uh I'm about
to send a link to Our Guest I want to
see if you guys get guess it one real
quick all right no doubt while we do
that I'll do the patreon questions oh
man here comes dipd dip down games and
Anime here we go a dimensional dragon
has appeared he plans on destroying the
world due to reasons unless the well not
the four of us right now the three of
you can agree on the three baddest
gaming villains of all time can you save
the world for a second time or will blow
up the sixth time when y don't
let's not addic our most controversial
person so hold up oh wait I'm sorry I
missed it we we have to put unite how
many of the three of the baddest V uh
video game villains world yeah it looks
like he did say gaming V villains of all
time so we got to agree on who are the
the three baddest I think I know what
addict one addict is already but let all
right so okay un lust the dimensional
dragon has appeared he plans on
destroying the world due to reasons
unless the three of you can agree on the
three baddest video game villains of all
time adct what is your yeah give me some
villain I know one of
them you g to say that dude from um
what's his name Jack of Blaze you always
go hard for Jack of
Blades no no Jack of Blades to say he to
say he's like the baddest villain of all
time I don't know if so let me put a
nomin even Sethro I don't know if I
would go with
him's powerful but the baddest of all
time like give me some villains give me
a villain so we can agree what is I mean
KFA kfka is up there stop okay kef
destroyed the world destroyed the world
literally lied the world consider I
would consider Sethro more of an
anti-hero that just did stuff for his
own stuff what about um how we feeling
about Atri that got big enough you beat
up you kicked them off the jum no once
again I would feel like atriarch is more
of
a a
um he's more of like an anti like he's
he's off of his own like in in order to
be considered a True Villain to me there
has to be criteria like you have to be
doing stuff strictly for evil and I
don't think that um I would
say Ganon I would say Ganon ganon's one
Ganon Ganon Ganon yeah Ganon yeah
everybody chat G um let me see what
about dick down says the clock is
ticking he's he loves put us in these
situations so KFA Ganon um did we agree
with I see you doing that final F he
says kefka in the acttion show did we
agree on
kefka
ke can't is pretty yeah he's I'm let him
I know what he doing I'm let him not
about this man and no no I don't want
you try to get your Final Fantasy 6
propaganda going again I'm not going to
bring him I'm not going to bring him up
if he's not going to do
nothing cuz he always starts our
arguments continue yo if you know what's
funny another one that kind of not an
argument but
um the boss of give me a boss aura's
wrath the boss somebody said the dog
from Duck Hunt I'm
done what about like a Wesker or like um
how we feeling about Wesker Wesker yeah
yes Wesker is definitely one of them he
is the definition of a bad guy yeah
Wesker so we had so we had Wesker who
was the first one we had that was good
wker wker and what D and uh Ganon Ganon
Ganon that's strong that's strong what
about
um Tomas running out the drag the
dragons
approaching I agree with those three I
like them three yeah that's it we need
three right yeah we just need three we
just need three it would have been four
we came with we got three no doubt all
right so next patreon question comes for
the homie Stitch 669 um okay let's talk
about it after seeing the review scores
for for Forza Motorsport I can't but
have to call out the media again the
game looks better runs better has more
options in game with an insane car
collection but yet lower scores to gt7
another game that suffers from the Xbox
tax addict your thoughts car Enthusiast
for a motor
reviewer oh I don't know any of the
cars do you think there is according to
stitch there's an Xbox tax that U media
bias about GT6
h i I don't know I I think there's a
bias in the media that might you know
vote down certain things but it's it's
to far as go say that like the media is
coming together to attack something I
don't know if I'll go that that far but
I do think there are people that don't
like when I think be are entitled I
think we can go that far I think that
you know some of the stuff we saw in
Starfield was because you know of
entitlement you know what's funny is the
media be telling me that I shouldn't
feel entitled but the moment you don't
give any of these people any kind of
access they they they they are on
campaigns like you know there's been
countless games that I haven't got a
review but I still reviewed
it with as try to be unbiased as
possible some of these media people
don't get a game when they get it they
give it a six out of 10 I don't know are
you implying that that the media is not
entitled to every review copy from a
from a game Studio what I'm saying the
media is some of the most entitled
people in the
industry inter you you don't give the
media stuff they they they're they're uh
they they have their little f
torches especially if it's a game they
were
anticipating let s Enix not give some of
these media Final Fantasy 7
rebirth and see how much energy
different sace they' be talking energy
different that's the only thing I just
don't like I don't like how the industry
ran in general with review codes but
that's that's a conversation for a
different day no doubt solve your
thoughts uh Stitch feel strongly about
Forza Motorsport and then Xbox tax is
there a media bias so I haven't I
haven't played it so I can't say I can't
say to what it is I have seen some video
that looks super impressive on the forza
end I haven't seen I I've seen like one
comparison video with like rain and
stuff yeah um you know comparing GT uh
GT to Forza so my expectation would be
that the game that comes out nearly two
years later would you know have more
advancements in terms of you know visual
Fidelity and quality and stuff of that
of that matter
um I'm surprised there haven't been more
overt conversations about like oh it's
not better than gt7 and they came out I
haven't really seen a lot of that
conversation digital a little bit for
minor like graphical things on the track
um but I just thought that would be a
conversation that would be really be
happening like on Twitter like big time
and it just hasn't really happened um so
again I can't really speak on it um it's
do I think sometimes I do feel like Xbox
games have an uphill battle
I I really do I I really do cuz again
people make comments sometimes like
again there was a video about uh I think
it was IGN something they were talking
about you know they were oh we're
playing Spider-Man and it would you know
one of the people on the video was like
you know I'm predicting right now we're
giving this game minimum of N9 out of 10
or something like that and it's again
it's not something that I go crazy over
but when you say stuff like that there
are people who are going to nitpick
every little thing that you say and say
hey you've played you know 10 hours of
this game and you're already saying it's
a it's a nine out of 10 or 10 out of 10
so you got to be careful with that sort
of stuff especially if you're in the
sort of if you're in the the sort of the
in IGN or something like that when
you're reviewing games so right I I I do
kind of feel like sometimes Xbox games
have uphill battle for whatever reason
it's like it's like every time they get
they go out there it's like you got
something to prove you got something to
prove whereas you know coming from a
Nintendo or a PlayStation it's you have
the benefit of the doubt right it's
different it's different so again I
whether they've earned that or not you
could debate that as well right to me
every game is a fresh start I think but
I get it I get how people could could
feel that way should that should that
translate into professional reviews and
probably not I would say no don't do
that fair enough add you gonna say
before I go I just I think my thing is
just like be genuine you know I feel
like some people use their form to speak
their personal beliefs and if they're
not heard they'll use the actual
platform to to speak their personal
beliefs and it's just like and then you
know part the biggest part of this issue
is people like uh companies like
Metacritic they they let it happen you
know when a company comes out there and
says that they're giving highi Rush is
six out of 10 because it's a Xbox game
and it's literally right there in stone
right and and and it's in
why is Metacritic letting that fly right
so it's like that's clear bias that is
bias to the to the definition I feel
that but you just letting it Rock no I
feel that I think that's where my thing
is like and I I got to shout out my
brother King on this because it's like
he's he's got the classic line no one
can tell me how my food tastes to me you
know at the end of the day these are
just outliers you know these are even
our side like it's one of our things
where it's like you you go to it if you
respect the opinion of the the platform
or the particular writer and you have
sensibilities with them you agree or you
disagree I think I always feel to go to
the people who are really knowledgeable
in that genre like that that's my thing
right and then the second thing is just
like look at the end of the day bias
exists we're all humans we all have our
inherent biases that's a fact you know
what I like is the people who could at
least be objective on the platform that
they're that's not their preference
right you know what I'm saying so I mean
that is excuse me that is their
preference so that you you can also get
a different perspective as well I mean
it it's one of those things as far as
Forza specifically you know where I'm at
with it I'm not the hardcore simulation
guy I said during my interviews with the
turn 10 team I'm the Casual guy I'm a
Forza Horizon guy right I don't haven't
played gr Tes mode since you know gr Tes
mode 2 you know pfy digital days back
with the replays and all that haven't
played it since then and you know to me
the hardcore guys are going to dictate
this from what I see the 84 to 885 is a
strong score for fora Motorsport people
are having issues more so with the car
RPG elements you know kind of thing um I
did see some graphical push back
initially from digital Foundry but then
I seen some stuff recently that blow me
away with like Forza in the water like
with the rain and that Jo got I was like
yo so you know look at the end of the
day you know use your judgment if if you
feel the outlet is biased then we got to
stop giving them power right you know
like why like why are we even support it
just go to the sites and the outlets or
or the writers that you respect the more
and don't give attention to stuff that
you think has that bias that's all I can
say but I actually have the opposite
effect yeah I I want you guys to trying
to Spotlight on
that because to me unless it's un you
know the the the the insects hide in the
dark so unless you put unless you put a
light on them they they're going to stay
in the dark what I will say to your
point earlier in reference to
like the Bethesda Starfield situation I
do feel I will say this and I'm never a
person that jumps out on this media
biased thing crazy but I will say first
of all no one is entitled to a review
code including us we are not we were
luck we were fortunate no one's entitled
that includes media Outlets journalism
as well so in my opinion you know what
when that happened in this particular
case I felt a certain subset of
journalist felt a way that they didn't
get it right so and the funny is these
same journalists would tell like you
know small influences like us that we
shouldn't feel entitled the moment they
don't but the moment they don't get it
exactly exactly so to me again this what
I look at St I don't feel that has
anything to do with the game because the
game from an engagement standpoint and
as far as millions of people playing it
we've already see what the what the
daily active users the monthly active
users are on Xbox most getting played
most get so the the the the majority do
not feel it's almost like that remember
like there like real like critic score
and user score that to me seems the
disparity with Starfield to me Starfield
is the only time where I seen that
example where I feel this is a bigger
issue and there was I seen some Outlets
say yeah and we're giving it a 72 as the
highlight of of nothing like that's the
the talking point so when I see that I'm
like I I don't know about that so look
people could review have their feelings
on how they feel feel a game if they
feel it's a certain score that's fine
but I do feel the Starfield moment was
in inflection for the first time major
Outlets did not receive it and there's
going to be some push back by certain be
fair when when is Major Outlets never
get again that is true it's very rare
very rare like in order to see you know
sometimes you gota you got to have the
light on bruises to see that there's
actual bruises like yeah look like I
said I don't I don't knock any game
company who says if we if we feel in the
past you have taken your reviews outside
of the realm of the gaming sphere and
made it personal attacks against their
team I don't feel it's out of bounds to
be like we don't feel comfortable with
you reviewing it and at the same time I
get it you know what I'm saying so it's
like look that's that's all I'm going
say on it as far as the uh media bias
whatever whatever but use your own
discretion go to the people you trust to
all the consecrators you trust and then
from there make your discernment as far
as which one you support so that's where
I'm at with that that um snail killer
hello fellow Lords this week we got a
lot of bad fan Behavior people trying to
spoil Spider-Man makes no sense is there
anything content creators and Gamers can
do to stop this shout out to addict to
calling the behavior out with some
people yeah I actually unfollowed those
individuals um sadly I was looking at a
Starfield post and was reading some um
some some of the comments and it was
video that popped up and I thought at
the beginning was Starfield I saw clear
Starfield gameplay so I clicked on it
started watching and like 10 seconds
into it was it was like the biggest
spoiler you could have damnn so I'm just
like I get it some people feel like you
know some of the PlayStation uh you know
toxic fans was being extra with with uh
Starfield but it's just like okay your
point yeah I got I had like friends ruin
whole plot plot twist in in Naruto 10
years before it happened in anime but
you don't see me acting that way it's
just like and then it's like I get it
you know you think you're attacking
PlayStation Fanboys but you're really
attacking me too you know now I got this
this spoiler that I didn't need to see
but I've seen it because some of you act
like this this Twitter stuff is real
life they out there they bang banging in
the street
it's like mute them and move on with
your life oh man that's hilarious so
your thoughts on now fan Behavior
spoiling games I mean just I don't know
man is it asking too much to for you
guys to finally one day just grow
up put the guns down yeah like come on
man you spoiling Spiderman what are you
doing nah son nah son they they was they
was they was doing dirt on my Starfield
nah I'm like yo and so the thing is okay
so people these aren't people that got
early codes they manag to get get their
hands on the game early right no the
these are people so what pretty much
happened is someone that got a early
code started spoiling the game and you
know it could have been to a friend and
a friend put on the internet and then
it's like a dominal fire but then you
know Xbox Fanboys took that and
weaponized it and now look look if you
put on there you put spoiler thing where
you click on it click that's thing they
gave my Starfield a seven I got
everything when you open up premium
Premiere and you and you play you put
some Starfield gameplay in there and you
cut and you put the spoiler in the
middle and yank it together to me we
fighting now like it's like you you this
isn't just you threw it on Twitter you
deliberately going out of your way uhhuh
to make this worse okay I mean you know
what it is is like I I still can't
process in my head that true true
fanboyism really exists cuz we sit here
we joke all right all right shout out to
the Lord P but here's the thing like we
it fa this it fair this to this
generation so it was bang bang gang gang
Genesis does with Nintendo during the
day when we went when we was in school
we it was it was it was a little bit it
was a little bit like you say dude but
it got to that because they started
doing it right cuz of the marketing
right because of our own accord I was
like oh damn I don't have that can I go
to your house and play can I go to your
house and play can I go to your house
and see that like you know what I mean
like it's not it was it was us falling
into the marketing speak like wait a
minute Genesis does what nend don't wait
a minute you know what I'm saying or or
the or whatever the nonf fight that was
the Sega Master System versus the NES
there was no fight there but um you know
us Master System has like but it's more
powerful it didn't matter it didn't
matter was more powerful so um I get it
though my thing is just okay I get it
when when I was a kid I get it these are
not children spoiling Spider-Man you so
he's a grown man the grown man grown man
spoiling Spiderman on the internet like
what is going on here like fair enough
yo again you could sit here and be like
oh these guys this Xbox Centric podcast
whatever you want that's all King King
will be the first person to tell you
don't you dare ever spoil Spider-Man for
me I would never do that to anyone and
it's it's just one of those things is
like come on man like you could sit
there you could talk you could talk all
the smack you want you could get into
debates you could do stupid things like
call to a show and front like you played
the game and didn't play like if you
want to go to that level yeah that
happened you can do that go to that
level whatever it's stupid but go to
that level but when you really
maliciously do something like put
spoilers to a story based game online
like come what's wrong with you like I
yeah come on I we we no one here about
that that behavior let's be real here I
I know I I say it's like because of the
stuff that happened with Starfield some
of these sers would have did this
without Starfield bang bang # remember
the seven remember the
seven remember we clap we on them I'm
even I'm even go
out you're not hurting IGN with that
though have Spider-Man they was laughing
at the the the the models and the hair
and the water hash said we got to spoil
all again let me stop yes please Lord
Paris what's going on kind of funny
xcast and of course the legendary
gamertag radio how we doing sir no I'm
doing good and first and foremost yeah I
know I know yall on like hour 16 do so I
apprciate stilling intros P intros we in
the pre this the pregame warm-up bab we
got our warm-up suits on we really
should start calling this
pregame the bucks on the by week that's
the only reason
I'm yes no but to what you just was
talking about being serious the
difference when we were coming up during
the 90s with Genesis and Super Nintendo
all that first first and foremost there
was no social media so you didn't have
all this Global interaction over this
stuff I'm sure you still had just as
many people that were just as Petty back
then but here's the difference we were
all poor at least I was poor facts yep
facts I had the Nintendo my buddy had
the Genesis you'd have somebody that
would have the Commodore or the turbor
graph 16
we were going to each other's house to
go play and borrowing and all that sure
you'd had a little smack talk or
whatever but it was still about playing
the games it wasn't about let me go
purposely try and spoil something for
you because you like the other brand
that I don't like or whatever crazy
stuff that's going on now and yeah I saw
the SP hey hey I saw the Spider-Man
spoilers but sorry I already beat it so
you get me spoiling it for me right but
uh it's the point of why yeah and I get
some of the backstory maybe y'all don't
want to go into it but sure there may
have been some harassment that was
happening but the counter isn't let me
spoil it for everybody yeah that that
that doesn't make sense to me that's
what I'm saying I didn't say nothing
negative about starfi and look where I
am sitting here spoiling on Spider-Man
yeah so is it's just it's where we are
now it's just a petty back and forth
like people like the review like look I
know I caught it a couple weeks ago cuz
I was talking about the Steam and
Starfield and review bombing and all
that kind of stuff I guess it wasn't
100% accurate but the point of people
going online purposely saying hey I'mma
go buy this game give it a bad review
and then refund my money buy it again
and give it another bad review is
everything that's wrong with all of this
well said imagine the amount of energy
that do that you should put that energy
to making a a video and you can get that
game before it comes out you yeah it's
is def say something before I jump in no
no it's just again that's what I'm
talking about like do you really this is
this is what you're doing with your life
is going out there and planning your day
around how am I going to bring the score
of this game down like what what's going
on man like oh man look man I'm a little
disappointed as I thought we was going
to be unified # remember the seven I
thought we was spoiling everything out
here all right I guess I got to be
mature about it you know what's funny
like all the people was that was
spoiling like all these Xbox people that
spoiling it I looked a none of them
followed me so that there's a reason for
that cuz I I never I never cosign that
kind of behavior I don't care what
happens like first off if Twitter is
bothering you to that degree where you
have to do that you need to uninstall
this thing yeah facts yeah if your whole
life is G gu up I'm interested to see
what king thinks about it because I know
somebody I think somebody mentioned it
on Twitter and he said something to the
effect is like I don't care about
spoilers in in superhero game because
you know how it ends the superhero going
go wi
anyway vintage King he's like the end
yeah even though that he don't care
about spoilers King ain't out there
spoiling oh yeah facts yeah he ain't
doing that yeah he ain't doing that no I
mean look that it is what it is I
totally agree with with with P totally
agree with s Everyone you know this is
ridiculous you know at the end of the
day it should never come to that any
energy dedicated to trying to ruin the
experience for others because you have
some type of emotional issue because
they did something to a game or you know
that you l or point out flaws of the
game you love is absolutely childish so
we got to be better we got to be better
that is crazy the fact that I heard that
I'm like man but I did predict it I told
people because of let's be honest the
there was a lot of pressure coming in
the Starfield there was a lot of
emotionality from both bases one base
saying yo this is the game could be the
game of generation that could you know
pull Xbox through another group stating
that you know I don't think so it's
going to be another flop you know or
whatever kind of thing and then when it
comes out both putting the energy to
support their both the little you know
the tribal belief I get it you know what
I'm saying it was a very important game
that changed the Z guys but yeah we got
we got to be better I I have a new
saying in what's the new saying don't do
anything that's Alex worthy video oh God
shut if you feel if you feel like you
might show up on a oh no it's Alex video
don't tweet that yeah don't do it don't
do it before you anyway that was the
last take from one like me I've been
trying to get in Alex video and I have
been unsuccessful so far so I think
you're doing well if you're
unsuccessful anyway we going to move on
those with the p Jo just get the poll
right quick uh last week poll results
are in the people spoken with the
preliminary approval by the CMA over the
X actually that is l Hold on that is the
lest one yeah know that is the latest
one over the um XBox deal what do you
think has the biggest impact to the Xbox
ecosystem once approved the winner of
the four-way ILP poll at 52% of the vote
was the infusion of the entire ABK
catalog into the console Game Pass group
coming in at second place at 21% of the
vote was PC game pass and mobile growth
group in third place raise a close 20%
of the vote was Call of Duty marketing
rights to the Casual Gamer and in last
place very disappointing with the realm
only
6% hold up let all right if I don't care
if they joking if they not joking if you
if you try to put in there like you like
a Prestige of like you're giving a
spoiler for Spider-Man mods get him out
of there no times get him out straight
up I won't hit anyone now the head but
after this if there's any spoilers for
Spider-Man there won't be no warning
there won't be no you will not pass go I
will get your $200 okay fact off with
the head now get him get him mod you
know what we do and um in last place
again only 6% of the vote very
disappointing Realm if we don't get
those Transformer Cybertron games in
Game Pass we F the ride this should have
been May higher this should have been
Paris I feel that the uh ABK deal is
hinging on the Transformers War of
Cybertron gave G1 heads we got to stand
United on this do you agree sir oh I a
th% agree and and if anything we can get
some new games univers H bro has Bros
did say right they they were interesting
Lulu did say she had the source code for
the hey we just got to call my man his
name d David terer from high mooon I
brother you're a legend we got to find
you we got to release you from Call of
Duty jail and we got to get these
Transformer Sabaton games my God I can't
take you guys serious right now spoiler
alert Peter Parker is
Spider-Man they messy they messy so s we
want to get a super chats that we start
this topic yes sir we got uh nintend
theotaku $5 Super Chat no king that's
like gunit without 50 D12 without Eminem
Call of Duty without zampella I paay for
this refund my tickets Please let's see
they thank you for the $5 Super Chat
you're not getting back corporate Cog
corporate Cog is here let's see if they
hit the like oh no they hit the like
ratio we will release King we release
King in a moment okay continue then we
got Dany passion official $2 Super Chat
Micah from Red Dead as a as a villain
yes Micah is a dirty
chato shout out to Micah shout M put the
CR in the chat for Cedric 8 member for
39 months Lord silver salute then we got
Danny passion official once again $2
Super Chat boss monegro Far Cry 3 yes
Voss is another bastard I was gonna say
him I was gonna say him but he's just
evil if we we need powerful villains I I
mean he's just yeah I don't know yeah I
agree then we have nintend andu again $
five Super Chat daily reminder that gt7
only scored as high as it did because
they added MTX and slowed progression
after reviews were dropped it's all a
lot yeah I remember actually you want
get technical I feel like that's that's
way worse practices
than after reviews were dropped that is
true yeah the progression was a little
rough then we have uh koki 54 $5 Super
Chat uh their media bias prefer company
when red like when Red Dead 2 lost the
god award 2018 in Game of the Year when
Red Dead 2 won most categories that year
that was you know that that was yes that
was
unjust Cory barlock crying sealed it
that was it that was that was a moment
that was a moment there we got zip Davis
$5 Super Chat did you know zip is a name
supported that Vasco can say out loud in
Starfield I didn't know that yeah just
call me Captain zip with the drip zip
with the drip salute my man then we have
lucious Augustus member for 25 months
Lord bronze these same people who didn't
get the code are making articles now
about how they've already forgotten
about Starfield huh interesting yes it's
rough out there in these streets we're
going to move
on they' got kid move remember for 40
months bronze moo with a brother
journalists were using Starfield as a
catalyst to jumpstart their careers and
use their status to get paid on X
Starfield was the perfect choice for
them Smo has opinions he's going in out
there he's out there he's
outside let's put the crest in the chat
for God Emperor sofa king who gifted 10
IOP membership thank you bro thank you
then we got smooth once again $5 Super
Chat PlayStation Fanboys asked for
Spider-Man 2 spoilers you had dudes
sharing Starfield leaks all throughout
the month of August you reap what you
see oh my hash remember the S wow that's
what we doing okay okay come on man put
the guns down put the guns down brother
peace and love let's no matter what you
say live is never coming back
Peter Mo yeah did say that continue yes
then we have let's play with each
other's joysticks $5 Super Chat banging
for a plastic box is stupid I only want
to bang S I mean bang for S wow damn we
need King with the beat man that was
crazy back to off thank you for your
donation thank you for your
patient your comat thank you thank you
sir black roaded three s remember for 20
months Lord silver spoilers don't mean
anything to me tell me the twist of
anything just means I'm going to have
some info going into it surprises are
for
kids I like surprises okay then we got
Nintendo daku $2 Super Chat hey yo this
King DLC looking kind of off yo don't be
coming for my man like
that then we have Angry hippie $2 Super
Chat how are you guys going to invite
Paris and not
Gary
messy yeah the the doors open for Widow
man wi we love wi we you know what's
funny yeah we got to get wi we got I
need to I need yeah I need to hear that
you know the F bombs with the British
ACC I got to go in yo can I tell y'all a
secret he gave y'all the smoke about
that
for so that was all a bit that was all
oh it was good it was so good he was
because if you notice Mike and I did not
stop laughing the right because we knew
cuz if I thought he was serious i' like
whoa
cuz if you didn't know you like yo he's
really in his feelings about this that's
that's just G that's just Gary I love
him it was classic salute to Lord W Gary
W we got to get him in the row man W
make your way over here we got to make
parents we got we we got to get W in we
got we got we got to reach out no doubt
what else we got then we got F gaming
member for 28 months Lord bronze thank
you Lords for always being there for me
you all know yeah I I'll always have the
Lord's back as well appreciate what
y'all continue to do for all of us
exctly appreciate brother rest in peace
to your daddy rais a good bed and again
our condolences brother we know you go
we'll put actually we'll put that link
in yeah for the GoFundMe for the
GoFundMe um yeah definitely then we have
dror Strange Love oh God here we go
sometimes it's normal Wars of people
whose mom don't love
them all right it's possible it's
possible now we got our brother hary
chany $5 Super Chat are you saying that
social media causes people to become
ridiculous no # live that no social
media life # no spoilers please yes no
spers you're a smart man to stay on
social media I give you you know was
funny I was
so like I don't really follow all those
people I didn't see it it was that it
was that Starfield man they got me with
Starfield they knew what they were doing
yes got to be careful out there man then
we have that lazy otaku $5 Super Chat I
feel like Peter Moore as head of
PlayStation would be a true true test of
Phil's willpower and Iron Fist Jim was a
test run Peter would be a real battle I
will say this you put the fear of God in
K you mention Peter boy as a potential
option the camera turned off turned off
he was disgusted continue There we have
that lazy atako once again $2 Super Chat
Master versus Apprentice sort of
thing could
be said you know Phil was was one of his
top soldiers you know he's over there
dealing with uh what was was what was
the guy that made Fable back in the day
M yeah yes yes yes continue dealing with
difficult yeah he said the most
difficult Studios people boy didn't say
that he said I felt bad for Phil I used
to send him out there to the most
difficult yo shout out to praic Nal
shout out to Milo shout out to Milo
shout out to Milo James Thomas to Super
Chat spoiler for any Spider-Man uh Venom
is the best character yes that's a
spoiler sh simbu abute and finally we
have Alvin $5 Super Chat my legit three
favorite games so far this gen are
probably chorus chorus is cool I like
chorus ship shooter yes death's door and
Cocoon which I haven't played yet I have
to play I goty from the inside this is
the power of game pass these hidden
diamonds absolutely yeah recognition so
we've uh got the pregame out the way
ready ready for the show hour 15 are we
are we unleashing the king first we we
will unleash let me just let me just set
let me set it up you know set it up oh I
didn't know what the first one was for
so we going to set it up we going to set
up so yeah this is my topic um Last of
Us factions yeah on ice this report
initially comes from Lord Jason Shri FR
of real at Bloomberg who um yeah he
actually shout him I ran into him at
Summer Games Fest recently it's been a
long time since I've seen him but um
yeah um the article was why PlayStation
initially the first article was why
PlayStation fans are cheering CEO's
departure Jim Ryan oversaw the
successful launch of the PlayStation 5
his fouryear tenure was also mared by
some flubs so basically the article goes
on to talk about the last two years Ryan
is overseeing a Playstation shift
towards games and service a popular
industry bu buzzword referring to video
games usually multiplayer that can be
monetized over long periods of time has
become an uncomfortable pivot for some
of Sony Studios which have spent the
last decade building out teams of
experienced developers to make big
cinematic adventure games that are
played solo so they talked about
obviously the still Blockbusters in the
works uh Spider-Man 2 which we know is
coming in a few weeks
um as far as the single player
Blockbusters and they said um but Sony
stable of game studios such as Naughty
Dog With The Last of Us Insomniac with
Spider-Man and Gorilla Games horizon
horizon has also been working on
multiplayer service games with mixed
levels of success most have not been
revealed yet some have been cancelled or
overhauled such as the online game based
on the last of us and then that kind of
led us into the kataku article which was
kind of titled Last of Us Studio naughty
dog is cutting Developers PlayStation
first party Studio behind Uncharted and
Last of Us is laying off dozen of
contractors so during the course of this
discussion of the contractors being let
off that's when they kind of talked
that's when we kind of learned about the
status of faction so basically according
to the article layoffs were Comm I mean
um sources tell uh kako that no
severance is being offered for those who
were laid off the contracts yada y y
then it says uh despite hit ratings for
the HBO adaption of The Last of Us a
multiplayer spin-off for the zombie
shooter based on the first game's
factions mode has struggled in
development Bloomberg reported in June
that Sony had diverted resources away
from the project following a negative
internal review by Bungie the recently
acquired live service Powerhouse behind
Destiny 2 One Source now tells Kotaku
that the multiplayer game while not
completely cancelled is basically on ice
at this point so yeah this kind of set
off a big you know Buzz as far as the
the status of um of factions which a lot
of people were really anticipated we
knew there was a Last of Us day recently
there was no mention of it so um before
we get into our panel I think the king
had be free for this he has he has
starts so we going to mute and let you
hear what he has to say peace and
blessings hey what's going on guys ah
you see what I'm doing that's why I
couldn't be there I got to give y'all
all the support y'all need in these
trying times because we know what
October is and October is a horrifying
month it's made even worse with the be
beginning of the
end I know a lot of y'all are saying
y'all Xbox dudes holding the line is
crazy and we held the line so I'll come
October the 13th Friday the
13th you'll be trying to hold the line
you got to go out and hold the line now
you see how I support I'm supporting and
I suggest that everybody that loves
PlayStation run out and get a
PlayStation VR2 go and support I know
it's not bad compat I know it's not the
best handheld I mean uh VR on the
market but you guys got to go out there
and support because these passion
projects need to be funded in order to
generate Revenue there's no return on
investment that's why Jim left Jim is
gone and you guys are in
disarray we heard
factions like I said Is On Ice Ice Ice
Baby isn't that right Dolph these dudes
they be acting like they number
one but it's all cat
but now on a serious note though
everybody got a chance to see what redf
did right yeah 60 frames a second what
you got to say now go back and fix your
face listen Phil Dominus Maximus really
Spen is not playing he's coming for your
head
pause so you know this Friday is the
beginning of the end and I want all my
PlayStation Brothers to hold the line
and go out and purchase go out and
support we got movies now with core I
know it was called Bravia before hey
PlayStation likes to do that they like
to say they got something and call it a
different name and make you think it's
something new it's not but you fall for
it anyway but hey hopefully next year we
can find out what's going to go down on
2024 cuz we have no idea at all Ro Ma
look kind of Bleak but we know when
Forza show up the generation start and
Forza just showed up and this deal is
about to close Microsoft has been
cleaning
house without even having this deal done
imagine what happens next stay tuned
where all the PlayStation dudes got to
hold the line cuz we held it and what
happened I told you if you don't believe
in them believe in me and remember I'm
98% right all the time well I wish I
could be there but I got to watch the
doo be brothers so you guys have fun and
enjoy
peace so
yeah there you have it uh thoughts of
the king you you've reached your goal
you we hit our weard our Target we held
the line for 300 likes and you got some
King boy you salute the king brother is
he he forsake us for the Doobie Brothers
today he could get out of it
it forsaking us but uh yeah to a
rerunning what's happening you know what
I'm saying but U salute that clearly he
wanted to give the real some thoughts
about the topics of the week so there
you have it but uh we got to get to our
esteemed guest Lord Paris um obviously
we've heard from the King but obviously
let's talk about this The Last of Us
factions you know the the potential news
that it could be on Ice what's your
thoughts about this whole situation now
look I understand that I might be the
Hydrox oh of of of iron Lords right now
trying to replace King okay you know the
Goot
flavor yo
but he's a mess he's a hot mess that
that that's just a hot mess now he hit
on some points that are
somewhat valid in in his own special way
the crazy part is the crazy part is king
would be saying the most outrageous
stuff but there's still some Realms
truth I mean to his point about they've
not even closed the activ they're saying
98% Paris 98% yeah 60% of the time it
works every time I know but
uh yeah they they're doing all this
without Activision so it they're not
depending on Activision to his point
fors is out now we got Starfield you see
a road map for what Xbox is gonna have
in
2024 now I know he's very tongue and-
cheek about PlayStation but he is
correct that we have absolutely no idea
what PlayStation's coming with in in
2024 now what I will not agree with him
on is the whole Jim Ryan thing because I
feel you have to take it at face value I
mean he's been there 30 years he walked
into a great situation with PlayStation
he's leaving Playstation still in a in a
good place right
so we'll never know the truth on what it
is other than to take him at face value
so I again I know he's being tongue and
cheek with all that stuff but um it it
will be interesting to see where
PlayStation goes next into 2024 because
we just we just don't know I mean the
only thing that we know about right now
is Wolverine yes and that's not going to
come next year that'll probably be 2025
um to and I was looking at the chat too
uh just like with Bungie and this whole
Last of Us factions thing yeah good if
if Bungie came in and and and as a
fellow Destiny head you know what I mean
if Bungie came in and looked at that
game and said hey this is not going to
keep long-term engagement you're not
going to be financially viable with this
game put it on ice then for exactly what
they're doing some of these other
projects that they're talking about if
those have been reworked or cancelled
then good let's not just throw a bunch
of stuff at the wall and see what sticks
because all it's because we we're seeing
where live service games are right now
anyways really the only two that have
remained viable are fortnite which keep
keeps evolving and and Destiny that's it
I mean the division is starting to make
a little bit of a comeback but we've
seen so many others die on the vine very
quickly prach that I would if I want the
last Vos factions to be honest with you
but I want them to do it right right so
if it's not going to be successful then
delay it I mean there it's not 100%
cancel but clearly they need to go back
in the lab and figure out what they're
doing but again to to to King's tongue
and point
what's coming in
2024 yeah I'm dying to know or is
PlayStation going to have their XBox
2022 moment cuz that's what it sounds
like remember Xbox had they had they had
the delay Starfield and redfall and all
we got was pendent right and and and
grounded 1.0 that's all we got yeah
that's is that what's about to happen
with PlayStation first party one thing
that we don't really take in account is
you know we say what's coming out 2024
202 5 and on it's like but maybe they
have been showing us like the majority
of the games that were in development
during the pandemic and stuff their
games the service games uh you know
maybe that's what they have in in the
talk for a little bit you know obviously
we'll see the Wolverine I assume ghost
of shima's in development too the sequel
to that game you know these games are
coming but I I said from the start it's
like you know people wanted to not give
Microsoft a little bit of leeway because
of like the pandemic and to a point I
agree but at the same time time it's
like I I'm I truly believe that Sony
just had more games closer to the Finish
goal before the pandemic hit so they had
a little bit of hiccups but they were
able to push those games to the Finish
goal the Finish Line yeah I think what
you're seeing
now is what Microsoft was dealing with
back then because the games that was
close to the Finish Line they were able
to push those in because they they were
doing the final touches of the game but
the games that was in full-blown
development during the pandemic like a
lot lot of Microsoft games were at that
time now you're seeing what these games
is what Sony was having issues with the
pandemic I guess I justess want to get
back to to Paris for a second um in
reference to what he said about
obviously you know the the quality of
the game and and I guess Bungie being in
there for oversight right to to kind of
review and see you know what where it
was at like ultimately I guess my
question is who do you think Sony made
if this report T to be true we you know
Jason's reporting tends to be strong
like do you think Sony ultimately makes
the call to fully cancel do you think
there's any chance of a Resurgence or
coming again because I've seen some push
back of people say Hey you know well
just they should have just released it
anyway we we still want to see what that
version is and that's okay break break
that down no I that I definitely
disagree if it's not going to live up to
a certain standard like when you think
of The Last of Us you're thinking of a
high quality quality AAA experience
right that pushing that into fact action
into a multiplayer component you I don't
think it's going to go away let me start
this way it's going to come out
eventually but clearly whatever it was
it needs way more time so that's why
you're you're seeing it go back in the
lab because that IP is just way too
valuable to to not put something like
that out so I just think yeah they're
going to go back rework it figure out
the the whole point of live service
games is to get you in the door look the
first hit's free you already know bring
them in and then have you so engaged
that you willingly want to buy these
micr and Jacksons and keep playing the
game so if that's what they need to do
if that's what they need to figure out
then that's what they'll do look it may
not come to a Playstation 6 but that's
okay I still think it happens the fact
that you already have part one you
already have part two those are
critically acclaimed great games the TV
show is critically acclaimed yes that IP
has Brand awareness now outside of
gaming so absolutely you want to have
something else that's going to pull
people in besides the first two games we
know any last of us three is for sure
PlayStation 6 you know it's not going to
happen anytime soon so if they need a
few more years to rework this and figure
out what you know to do it the right way
then that's what they're going to do
that just that just makes sense to me
they would it would not be viable in my
opinion to just completely cancel Last
of Us factions because I do think
there's a market for it clearly there
are people as as you're saying that want
to play it that want to see it but let's
just make sure we do it right let's not
have it come out we're excited for a
month or two and then it's just goes
away because nobody's playing it anymore
no fair enough fair enough addict
wouldn't finish your bars on on the
whole situation in reference to you know
obviously the the news that the game
Last of Us factions is on
Ice um I'm a little half and half with
Paris um I do think that they are
looking at the The Last of Us it wasn't
cancelled uh could be just a variety of
things with their like we don't want to
come out and announce a game that's been
cancelled or it could be one of those
things where it's like we got to
restructure we got to figure out you
know what exactly you know maybe Bungie
will work with them more on the on the
you know the uh the monetization part
because I think that's the true thing is
like the monetization because last was
factions BG maybe they're trying to
casualized the game because if you go in
there right now factions factions is not
an easy multiplayer by any
means and it you know it could be a
variety of that I personally feel like
if they don't go back and rework I agree
with pairs that won't be cancelled I
think they'll restructure it and add it
on to The Last of Us Part Two remake or
last of us three as a factions to that
game before they just cancel it entire
you think they'll go away from the
Standalone I'm just want to be clear it
just depends if they're able to find a
middle ground with Bungie and find out a
way to monetize the game because I don't
think that son is just going to continue
to throw uh more and more money at it I
do think there is an end point and
clearly you know you you see all the the
the contract workers got laid off yeah
you saw uh you know they they they
started they've already started funling
less money into it it reported happened
in June now you got reports that's being
on Ice to me that's either we need to
find out what we truly want to do with
this or do we want to take the work
we've already done now restructure it
put it with the Last of Us Part Two
remake no fair enough fair enough Lord
solve Last of Us factions rumors on ice
what are your thoughts on
this I really do feel like that product
is mostly finished uh to addict point I
think it it the thing is how do we
package this how do we sell this how do
we you know how is it do we turn it into
a free to play thing do we sell this as
a $70 thing point I do I do think it's
the mon ization and I think I think a
lot of you know the fact that the the
person that they brought over from um
from epic to work on that leaving yes is
perhaps a little bit telling right um
that that you know maybe there was kind
of buding of heads there in terms of how
to monetize this and just to be clear
not to cut you that was the person from
every dealt with fortnite's monetization
yes okay got it so you know somebody
who's kind of an expert in how to how to
make something turn something into a
living breathing sort of thing that can
survive for for a long time um but it
goes back to the point that I argued
when we first heard about this a couple
of months back where it was like why
does it need to be that um and and again
maybe that's just me being idealistic
because the moment you turn that from a
a you know from a mode in Last of Us
Part Two into its own game it obviously
has to expand into something bigger and
grander right um you know a $70 product
so to speak so um but what I always
assumed it was it was something that was
going to be a little more cinematic
narrative sort of Base but it gave you
that sort of that multiplayer sort of
what you what you got from factions
originally in the in the original game
just expanded upon and with maybe some
storytelling around it that kind of
gives you insight into the world of the
last of us as opposed to these
characters that you know of already in
that World um so that's my impression of
what that was um and then you have
Bungie come in and again this is us
assuming you know the amount of power
that Bungie has within Sony to say no
yes no um but if there is a thing where
it's like hey Bungie's thinking about
where these games need to be and what
kind of products they need to be is this
living ongoing thing we have to figure
out a way for people to to be to for
this game to be sticky right for for for
two three four years whatever the case
may be real quick S I don't think Bungie
has the power to go in there and you
know just shut stuff down oh no not say
like shut it down but they their
suggestions hold a lot of way yeah I
think it it's it's like that you know
they when they showed the report and
they're okay elaborate what you mean the
is report then they went back to to
naughty dog with factions I was like
this is what Naughty Dog thinks of this
mod how do you expect how debate it you
know it's like it's like how do you
expect to you know go against the grain
that n that that Bungie here has and I
don't think naughty dog passed the uh
they didn't pass the checks man they
didn't yeah when it come when it comes
to creating that type of game that bung
known for now um yeah I just think
there's just sort of butting up heads of
how they sell this game how they allow
this game to live and I just sort of
think that you know Bungie's design
ethos was we're going to give you this
cool multiplayer we we're going to wrap
it up into a a more sort of pristine
kind of quadruple a product that you
sort of expect from Bungie with some
story with a little more context for the
world of The Last of Us and do it that
way but not necessarily expecting people
you know the people who gravitate to it
and love it are going to play it for a
long time but beyond that maybe not
create uh systems within the game which
kind of you know the carrot on the stick
thing that you have with with with
Destiny and other sort of uh live
service games where it's like okay what
do we do to bring them back week over
week we engagement
yeah I'm I'm sorry I don't know how to I
don't know how to interject on please
please just do just do we we jump in
that's we jump in just jump in brother
yeah we we we jump in but I'm the only
one that gets repercussions for it well
you do yourp you do it the most you do
it the most but we G to let you ride
Contin no but ironically enough as as
we're talking about this I'm thinking
there's another game in company that's
doing the same exact thing but not
getting the publicity because it's all
rumor and speculation on this project
even existing but 343 and and Halo and
Tanaka or Tatanka or whatever T yes I
mean think about it 343 just went
through a major restructuring leadership
contractors got laid off we obviously
don't know with certain Infinity of of
any layoffs or restructuring that may
potentially happen with them but again
if you go by R in speculation Jess
Cordon that game has evolved into
something a lot bigger than what they
originally planned because remember it
was just supposed to be an add-on to
Halo infinite where now it sounds like
it's going to be its own Standalone
thing so maybe this is similarly what's
happening with factions where we had an
idea for it we realize this isn't going
to have a long tale let's restructure it
and turn it into something bigger and to
sv's point maybe it does want maybe it's
not free to play maybe it becomes a $70
purchase that has you know DLC and
microtransactions attached to it because
now it has its own story and its own
thing that makes it stand out that no
it's not the last of us three but it's
in The Last of Us universe and there's
like a co-op or multiplayer component to
it so I I get you know these articles
come out and and and we see it at for
what it is like oh wow it's on Ice
contractors got laid off this isn't good
but maybe there is a long-term plan with
this where look we need to scale it back
for now we need to replan and then when
we're ready to go back into full
production we can rehire because it's
contractors wer laying off they weren't
laying off like Naughty Dog employees
right maybe now we can hire some more
contractors and go back into full
production on this in another year to 18
months who knows yeah that that's what
makes sense right that the fact that the
contractors if you if you're putting it
on ice the contractors don't have
anything to do because they're the work
guys right so yeah um while they figure
out what they're going to do with this
um yeah it doesn't make sense that
they'd be there but I really do I hope
it comes out I hope that they by the
time it comes out that you know 50% of
it isn't on the cing room floor right I
hope that we do get this really I hope
that the vision that they have for it is
able to come out as intact as possible
um and maybe maybe that's being
idealistic maybe the you know the the
their design ethos coupled with making a
a service based game just doesn't mesh I
don't know yeah um but I really do hope
that that doesn't mean this game just
never sees a light of day because that
would suck and again it's a lot of time
sunk into something that's ultimately
not coming out for a studio that only
drops maybe one or two games per
generation as it is so you know if this
is if this ends up just going away
that's years sunk into something that's
not happening so um that sucks no well
said I agree with both what what
everyone's saying this this is tough
because um you know on one hand I you
know I saw Jason's article I respect the
PIV I know a lot of people give Jim Ryan
a lot of you know grief for for some of
the moves and some of the things you
said I get it but as far as to Pivot the
live service I always felt solely needed
to do this you know to kind of stay
viable that's how the industry is
changing so but live service is hard you
know it's it's very difficult you have
to you know the monetization model to
get people coming back and then the
thing I also want to kind of not dispel
but I'm seeing this talk that it's like
because this is Naughty Dog right this
is the great Naughty Dog how can
anything they put out not be quality
there is a distinct difference between
you know making what I consider player
games as a service hash just one which
they have arguably one of the Masters of
right then to make a viable multiplayer
game that is consistent and I agree with
Paris in the sense that you know there's
a quality bar there right and and and
also not just a quality it has to be an
engagement bar and to me the way it was
being treated when we first heard of it
we like okay where is it should be
attached to the last of us you know
remake or whatever and then we heard
okay no it's going to get it Standalone
game so at that point you thinking it's
more robust it's going to you know have
more features and things of that nature
and then obviously we get the report so
the way I look at it is it's either two
things happen it's either in my opinion
you know obviously Bungie part of the
reason why they were acquired was they
are going to have their expertise leaned
on for PlayStation game studios during
this pivot so when that happens to me
it's like okay check this out it's
either a the game is fundamentally not
good at a gameplay loop at its core
right and then Sony maybe shuts down
cuts his losses and obviously QA is let
go or whatever right and we know that
they have a very high quality bar at s
from from a Metacritic standpoint that's
one possibility I'm thinking another one
is that it is a solid multiplayer game
it's a good multiplayer game but maybe
not a good live service game not a game
like s you said sticky retain you know
engagement getting people to come back
and I kind of I kind of think of in a
way Halo infinite at launch we could say
what we want the core game was fun
amazing it was fun it was am like it was
so good as far as just the the minute
to- minute game play and engagement but
what we started to learn as he went on
right the monetization model wasn't
there I mean the um you know the live
service model wasn't there the content
make you keep coming back the Skins the
events it was kind of bare bones and
then it started to suffer now now
they've come back but to son many point
maybe they don't want to wait you know
two years three years to go through any
type of growing pains and lose on
investment so the other thing we got to
look at is you know we're in a world of
free to play right and I think Paris you
touched on the monetization model right
what what kind of works do we make it a
$70 game Standalone right but then maybe
they say hey in a world where fortnite
is free right in a world where a lot of
these games are free to play you know
would have to be free to play right do
we get that stickiness and then you know
it's one of those things and I think I
had this conversation with Rand and I
was just like in my opinion cuz I play
Live service I play Destiny all you know
all stuff all the time in my opinion
it's it's kind of hard to not do free to
play and and on multiple platforms cuz
we know like for example they've been
with the PC ports it's been kind of like
one year later for Sony right so the the
argument is can you drop a $70 game and
limited a live service game to just
PlayStation they can't no that's I agree
I agree I agree that's another that wall
Garden thing is not going to work it
doesn't work for live so in my opinion
I'm with you s like you've got to get
the most players the most engagement so
you kind of have to break that
rule and and say hey it's PC also day
one right and you got to have a good
model to make people come back and the
last thing I'll say is just that look
obviously I'm a huge fan of bung I saw
some some talk going on Paris I was my
feelings man they was like yo they how
dare these dudes they they should have
just dropped them I don't like the power
they got over there and look I get it
but let's be respectful this is the
creator of Halo the creator of Destiny
regardless of how you feel about Destiny
you can't knock the engagement and the
longevity what is it almost what is it
2014 well they they're they're about to
hit their 10e plan they're about with
final shape talk about it 10 years in
the game we've been through all the
destiny Killers you know what I'm saying
the anthems division one division two I
can't play two years of my life and they
doing 10 10 years of play like coose to
playing this game so again we take the
out of it hey they've had their ups they
had I'm not going to say the game's
perfect they've had their ups they had
their down but you cannot deny the long
as of I look right now I think it was
like top 10 or just outside the top 10
right now during all the the the crazy
PR stuff that's going on bu you right
now and yeah I think what makes them you
know another thing that people don't
acknowledge is the fact that what makes
them so good at what they do also is the
extent of their failures as well because
absolutely when you look at this this
this model that they that they sort of I
won't say perfected right but that they
really have a handle on it's almost like
the the the valleys are planned for like
you know hey we're gonna suck right here
but we're gonna bring it back up and
then we're gonna go back down and it and
it's this undulating thing that you
almost expect as part of the process so
when they look at you can't say Bungie
has just had crazy success in this space
without understanding how to get there
and just sometimes somebody has success
from the jump and they never fall and
they don't see what it takes to to kind
of build themselves up to a certain
level or or or sort of deal with
adversity they've dealt with adversity
at every turn so when they look at a
faction and say and and for me like I
said I'm I'm of the mind it maybe it
doesn't have to be this game that lives
for 10 years yeah I'm cool with it being
something that I mean but Sony Jam Ryan
went 10 live service games correct and
that's that's another question to ask
right does whoever come in comes in
do they follow that Mantra or do they
say hey we I don't need this particular
game to be that um and and kind of roll
that back right because I do feel it is
a Jim Bryan sort of Mantra where it was
like hey we need these to be this right
and we at least see what we have if we
put this type of game out there so yeah
I I think what makes Bungie so good at
what they do and the fact that you know
so this push back you're getting like oh
they shouldn't have this PO the fact of
the matter is they understand the highs
and they understand the lows right so
there's nobody better to have brought in
to be like hey this works this doesn't
work this work this doesn't work because
they understand the entire spectrum of
it is what I would say no absolutely and
I agree you know what I'm saying it's
definitely been trial by fire and and at
the end of the day you know they've been
able to make the successful pivots
whether it's self-imposed or not you
know I mean when during you know
Destiny's run to be able to do a console
live service game and continue to have
the engagement they have you cannot deny
the engagement but last what I wanted to
say which is that um what I do find
interesting is I want to know what you
guys think about it in reference to the
Jason sh report saying that his inside
sources are saying that PlayStation
Studios have an
uncomfortability with the pivot some of
them with the pivot to live service and
that as traditional single player game
makers now with this new edict from up
top that we're going to need you when
you see Sony Santa Monica's name and you
hear Naughty Dogs name and you know some
of these Studios these traditional
amazing games now having to be make this
style of game what do you feel about an
uncomfortable pivot like do you think
that that this could cause unrest
because developers want to do what they
want to do or they're just in a the the
Pains of a transition like what do you
think Paris I'm just curious okay so you
want to get me in trouble yes I'm not
I'm trying to get in trouble I see what
is happen I got bamboos
onou got to get you making those tough
questions man you're good at here's what
here's what could happen I and it's
ironic because you didn't mention
gorilla and all of that of of all their
major Studios gorilla would probably be
the most comfortable because with their
Kill Zone Legacy so they have
multiplayer experience but that's the
exact point you're asking Studios that
traditionally have not done multiplayer
components to now start doing not only
multiplayer but a full on monetized life
service component as well so there there
is going to be unrest with that there is
going to be uneasy with that and here's
where I'm going to get in trouble let's
go What will What potentially could
happen is you see top talent leave and
go elsewhere that's what could happen
especially if hey I don't want to make
multiplayer games I like making I don't
know God of War or whatever right why
are you trying to make me make God of
War the multiplayer game I don't want to
do that I'm gonna go somewhere else
where I can continue to make the things
that I want to make since we're talking
Bungie and all that why do you think
Bungie if you go back and look through
their history left Xbox in the first
place they didn't want to be the Halo
Studio they wanted to start doing other
things so if all of a sudden these
studios are being made to do things they
don't want to do you're going to see
people that have the skill set and the
talent to go I didn't sign up for this
I'm out of here very I'm not saying it's
gonna look look try try not to get in
too much trouble I'm not saying it's
gonna happen right I'm just saying that
opens up the possibility for it to
happen so we'll see no I think that's
fair solve adct what your thoughts on
that quick before you move
on so can go first there's noise on the
backround no you good um yeah I do think
see if if there was a if there's a pivot
within Sony first party that is that
black and white that's a stupid I mean
that's just stupid now now you're
telling people that have been making X
type of game for decades you're going to
Pivot to this and you're going to have
to learn how to you're going to have to
figure this out right and that's the
part that kind of doesn't sit well with
me I mean they they they made all these
other smaller purchases specifically I
thought to to focus on that sort of
stuff right the names of the studios
Escape me right now but they have a
bunch of new acquisitions that kind of I
felt fire fire Sprite and things of that
nature that that I felt were sort of
working on those types of games Jade
Raymond Studio things of that nature
right so my thinking was okay we're
going to bring in these Studios to make
these type of games with you know Bungie
sort of overseeing everything
in addition to whatever bung making
right bung's next game is obviously
going to be on all platforms but
obviously it's going to have that
PlayStation sort of stamp of approval on
it right
um and I figured the the studios that
were making you know the the single
player just just ones or whatever were
going to be left alone if that is a
mandate a true mandate from within then
you're not reading you're not reading
the last 10 15 years of the industry and
what happened when you tried to tack on
multiplayer game game play to games that
had no business having it you know yeah
attacking on multiplayer to Bioshock two
or something like that like just to be
clear I just want to interrupt for one
second so the report says that even
though single player Blockbusters are
still in the work Sony stable game
studios Naughty Dog Insomniac Gorilla
Games have also been working on see it
appears to be separate multiplayer I
just want to be clear like that
necessarily add-on but that's where some
of the uncomfortability it's like they
they big say being told but the rumors
that they that they also have to work on
these separate multiplayer games as
opposed to like an add-on game listen
nobody likes to take a part of their
team and and you know and and sort of
section them off to do something
different when you're working on a big
project if that is the case I feel for
them because again I get that at the
same time if it is not invading the
actual single player product that
they're working on apart from taking
away resources but if if the Mandate
isn't you know uh fit this into you know
your next single player uh narrative
Adventure I'm fine with it um again
things will play out the way they will
play out and if the quality of the of
that game suffers as a result of trying
to make this multiplayer thing it'll you
know it'll be evident and hopefully
that'll change Minds internally um but
yeah to me that I get it and to paris's
point the industry well now you know
there was a while while that you know
the the the the the eating was good out
there you could leave and you were going
to get you could leave just for the sake
of leaving and and if you had the
credentials you were going to get a
pretty nice package wherever you're
going things have kind of shifted a
little bit where it's you know you you
have to worry a little bit about
stability um but yeah at the end of the
day if you're being forced to do
something that you don't have expertise
in that you don't want to do these guys
are going to up and leave and they're
going to start migrating to other places
and there you know again you have a you
have a new Nintendo console on the
horizon and I'm sure they'd love to have
devs you know working on that you have
Xbox always on the on the
Lurch for for devs um especially you
know again trying to sort of fill out
you know the game pass catalog and stuff
like that you will see there will be
places for these types of devs to go
yeah so again that type of mandate to me
no matter how you implement it feels
sucky and weird um but again I get it so
it it it's going to be interesting to
see whomever comes in if some of this
stuff gets rolled back and and not not
because last week I said hey whatever's
been whatever's been put into play it
the ball is rolling right I would say
you you mostly have to see that through
and then see and then pivot from there
if it if it really fails miserably um
but at the same time I think there are
certain things again I I'm sure with new
management coming in you have the the
heads of these Studios talking to them
BL hey there's certain things that we
were asked to do that we're not super
comfortable with is there something that
we could could do to sort of roll some
of this back you know not necessarily
you know dip a toe in but not you know
things of that nature so you know we'll
see how that plays out but uh yeah
anytime it's never a good thing when
you're asked to do something that you're
not comfortable doing or have not done
before it's never panned out well I
think even when we look at the the the
the gorilla example these guys took
years to Pivot to this other thing right
in the background um
to yeah even know that the devs that
made kills though a a large part portion
of them I don't know how many of them
are still at gorilla right that's true
that's a good point those guys could
have migrated away to someplace else to
make fpss right so I don't know I I
really don't know what this what this
does but um if it if you
seem if that is the case it's not it's
not good because the results have never
been good history will tell you that the
results of of of doing things like this
have never been good so no doubt ad me
get your thoughts to it quickly cuz I
got to get I want to ask p one last
question cuz I know he's got to go soon
but addict your thoughts on on that
whole last part portion we talking about
I mean if if you know they're truly
being forced to make a game like that I
I agree of Sol 100% you know even if
it's just a small portion of the studio
uh they're going to need leads to some
degree uh because I I I would assume
they wouldn't put nothing but you know
uh newcomers that's in the industry in
here I assume that there are some
prominent members of their studio in
this so I think it's just one of those
things where it's
like you bought
Studios to make these games if it is
true that other like their core Studios
the people that make single player games
and they're kind of being pushed in this
direction as well then why did you buy
those other Studios you know it's like
the the PC portion you know they usually
parked her up with the studio they're
making they were bought for the PC ports
and they've been doing that yeah Nexus
so you know to me bring it you want like
dedicated multiplayer teams so to speak
Studios now if to me if it would make
more sense to have okay you know we
tried this it didn't work let's let's C-
develop some you know let's have uh this
multiplayer Studio that we bought that
has been nurtured that's the reason
Microsoft tries to keep things in the
same willhouse because for the most part
if they do decide to on that franchise
they want people that know what they're
doing in that type of genre know what
they're doing have experience in there
you know a lot of developers are very
versatile but certain jobs require an
expertise that a lot of people don't
have I get you one is which one is it
that got the destiny form of people over
there is it fire Sprite fire always
foret fire walk fire walk yes yeah
they're making that they got A plus
multiplayer they got a lot of lot of
good talent over there for multiplayer
they got yeah they pretty much got the
the core multiplayer Team for Destiny
went over the firewalk yeah sorry so
when it comes to something like that
it's you know let them do it you know if
they feel like that's gonna work out for
them I don't think it is you know we've
seen countless times that you know if
developers doing something they don't
want to do the passion's not there like
agree when the passion's gone you see it
in the product absolutely
exactly yeah no well said I think NE
even said that as well you know but I
wanted to get pass before he Le I know
he's got a goal I did want to get his
thoughts on the next top before he lead
which is ABK potentially being imminent
if we are if the rumors are true shout
out to Tom Warren you know um do what
what do you think man about that Saga
and it potentially conclud and the joke
of potentially Friday the 13th which I
know King is having fun with you know
with that part but what are your
thoughts if it is to conclude next next
week this long Saga 20 months yeah that
that Friday the 13th almost seems
intentional but um personally finally
you know it can be over so we can stop
the speculation and wondering what's
going to happen um I would imagine a
couple things I would imagine you'll see
you'll see Phil and and the senior
senior leadership team come out we get
the round table we get the couches like
like they did with Bethesda and kind of
just set those expectations on what this
deal will will mean for Xbox in the
short term and then obviously long term
I would not expect all these titles to
be their day one on Game Pass there
going to be all kind of crazy licensing
and contractual things that'll prevent a
lot of that stuff from happening but I'm
and I think King actually mentioned on
this or someone did but I'm actually
more Curious on the PC side yes that was
me that was because I'm thinking World
of Warcraft obviously is any is there
going to be some type of Game Pass
incentive I wouldn't expect a full-blown
subscription but I would imagine PC game
pass gets a lot more incentive for Games
like World of Warcraft on the PC side
whereas you'll get some kind of discount
things like that so clearly everyone's
like what's gonna happen with Call of
Duty with all those things like I said I
would not hold my breath sure maybe some
of the Legacy stuff will show up early
on what does that mean for some of these
IPS that are owned by Activision that
have kind of been mothballed like we're
joking about Transformers what does so
that's where I would love to see Phil
and the team come out and kind of
address that like what is that going to
look like what is the road map for the
future of these Activision Studios look
like what is some of the collaboration
that we'll see across all of Xbox game
studios like I think of of battle battl
net what does that mean for the Xbox app
on PC right good point all these kind of
Integrations and and they're not all
going to happen day one but I'm sure
those conversations are happening and
what we can expect longterm like I would
think by the time we get to the next LA
Xbox sum game Fest E3 whatever they're
going to be calling it you'll probably
see some major announcements with
Activision what they're doing with
Activision IPS and integration in the
game pass and just some of the other
services that Activision already has and
let's not forget final thing this deal
was not about I was just about to ask
you right my mind goad go for it go
preach go what you about to say not
about console it was not about PC this
was about mobile that that's where the
big prize is and that's where I think
you're going to see them expand Game
Pass in the mobile because now they got
King now they got all that stuff so that
that's what I think I I but I I do
expect within the next couple weeks
you're gonna see Xbox leadership come
out and talk about this Pro it could be
as soon as what where what is it the
13th so Friday it could be as soon as
that Monday Monday yeah possibly so now
that they acquire King David last final
question is um do do we get that Candy
Crush though we get that Candy Crush in
the
G what you think I I think you might
okay I think you might it'll be funny me
they show you the moment where they
transfer the payment from from that goes
that goes from Activision they oh now
now it's transferring over to Xbox you
just see the money
going that is literally what they wanted
the faris's point the the fact that that
money is now funneling into Xbox candy
crust is is Beast out here it's a beast
it's a monster it's absolutely
one last thing and I know this is a
topic you have down the road but I do
want to touch on the redfall update
really quick yes other than to just say
I do applaud Arcane for sticking and and
again I'm sure Xbox leadership and all
this has Bethesda has a part to play in
this but Arcane did not give up on it
they did deliver on their promise of 60
frames obviously was we know the launch
wo the disappointment and all of that um
so for console player because look I
played on PC so I already had 6 bro I I
was fine yeah but that isn't the issue
with redf I think the bigger part of
this update was AI improvements they
added Stealth In other words they are
trying to truly fix the game it's not
all going to happen with just this one
update I understand that but maybe there
is a Redemption for it may maybe there
is I I would I would love to see it I'm
I'm gonna be honest I'm not holding my
breath yeah not holding my as far as
that goes but at least they are trying
to do it and that's all that you can ask
for it was a disappointing launch look I
may or may not have been in the room and
had to as those questions bro you had
the let's give you you had the interview
the Phil interview of the Year let's
give you your flowers while you here
uncomfortable you as the tough questions
brother we we appreciate that continue
yeah look very uncomfortable interview
that's 100% on both sides I'm sure but
it had to been asked at the time because
that game in my opinion never should
have seen a light of day I'm sure
there's Lessons Learned yes that came
out of that and I would hope and expect
that we don't see a repeat of that
moving forward another words this is why
you saw Starfield launch in a in a
quality State Forza for the most part is
launched quality now I would expect
moving forward games like a V hellblade
2 on Down the Line we're GNA see launch
in a better State than what redfall did
and if it isn't ready delay it delay it
period well said again the legendary
Paris ly dropping in the realm holding
us down you know what I mean again
brother appreciate you love what you're
doing out here had good watching kind of
funny xcast this week you guys have me
dying I loved y sporting out there the
forza whips that that was kind of fire
salute to yall wait wait oh I already
put it I I got the helmet oh you got the
helmet I got the helmet that was clean
and again bro I love what you doing
gamertag radio the OG's in the game and
finally I'm always proud to see you
whenever whenever you hit the stage
whether it's Microsoft flight simulator
whether it's Xbox I'm like this my man
he do and give keep giving Kai the smoke
cuz it's funny yes and we love you K we
love you
but let me let me let me say this before
before I I I I sign off here really
quick I I love like I I'm sad that I
missed Pax this year because you're
always packs I was supposed to be there
family stuff came up last minute I
couldn't be there because I love what
y'all do I know I joke about y'all do 20
20 24-hour podcast but you are very
important in this space I love that the
iron Lords are here you guys have had
amazing interviews and get yourself bro
you just had Peter Mo thank you brother
right you know stuff like that I'm glad
that you and I got to finally finally
yeah got got to hang out and all that
and it's important man that we we do
this we all support each other we all
rooting for each other and uh just none
but continued success for all of you
much love the legendary and wait and and
and because I feel like I'm leaving out
and adct we got to finally meet face
finally we didn't we didn't get in fist
fight the two tallest dudes of both
podcast got it it n salute to you
brother appreciate you no doubt Paris
Lily y'all have a good rest of oh I was
we got six more hours we got six more
hours to go it it was definitely nice uh
you know meeting your Paris at uh la la
was just weird in general this year I
don't know why like yeah it was a weird
one but it was fun to see everybody man
parents enjoy your hey game awards game
awards December oh we going see we may
we may it's 50/50 with us you got to hit
your people up to let us
know heyy that's key that Ain me oh
that's
ke so all right have a good one man all
right brother have a good one later no
doubt no doubt oh I see Cole East one in
the chat is that co co what you doing
man I thought you was on this usually
the LA I don't us see you in Sunday holl
at attic right quick to get you in here
I'm literally talking to him right now H
Co cuz I actually want his opinion on
something he would be a perfect person
has
something no doubt oh s we got the uh
Super Chat sir I got to make a quick
little
r yeah handle that we got
we got Nintendo on De taco2 Super Chat
hey yo this King DLC looking kind of
off oh no no we got this already hold
on people with
moms why did I roll back so much oh we
got Cedric H uh gifted five IOP
memberships thank you brother appreciate
that put the Crush in the chat for
Cedric H then we have BT Maverick 707 $2
super chat release the Kraken yes you
got Kraken King you Kraken King with the
psvr2 on his face then we got 99 ruken
$5 Super Chat when the Activision deal
closes what if Microsoft releases all of
their Spider-Man games on game pass the
same day Sony releases Spider-Man 2
reactions that would be that would be
funny that would be funny then we got
Suicide Kings $2 Super Chat it's good to
be the king yes yes yes it is then we
have EG Kenta $2 Super Chat that PS fan
too loud in the background somebody's
fan fan was whing out in the background
I don't know who's then we got God
Emperor Sofa King $5 Super Chat question
for Paris if the Last of Us Part Two
multiplayer gets cancelled should Sony
be worried about being subjected to a
class action lawsuit since it was
promised uh yeah we've seen that with
what I forgot what was the recent thing
that we saw with that that it was
something was promis and then it was I
don't think you have to worry about it
as long as they didn't like take money
from people like yeah that was the thing
what was it what was the recent thing
that there was a lawsuit over I can't
remember what you talking about oh there
was a question for Paris from God
Emperor over King and he said I asked if
the last ofos part two multiplayer gets
cancelled should Sony be worried about
being subject to a class action lawsuit
since it was
promised I don't know that's a good
question and I was thinking about
there's something there was recently in
the news about something that was
promised and there's a class action
lawsuit going on oh yeah there's a game
I know what you're talking about yes
that people were like yo and they
canceled it damn MADD talk was talking I
forgot the name completely forgot what
it was and we got hary chani $10 Super
Chat PlayStation already had a down Year
in 20121 with Ratchet and Clank and the
show being their only new uh first party
games Xbox released ghostwire for
PlayStation in 2022 hell divers 2 and
Concord are slated for 2024 plus the
show games as a service games yes this
is what they have so far now we got to
remember to though like PlayStation's
first quarter in terms of second party
and third party exclusivity however long
that may be still kind of like you have
you have rebirth coming yeah for sure
yeah you got rise of the Ronin coming
you got that other one something blade
Stell blade or something like that shout
out to Jean Lord Lords gaming.net and
Lucius Augustus it was cotor to uh
switch DLC yes the switch DLC that's
right that's
right okay then we have slow-mo back
slap member for 39 months Lord Bron Sony
would have been better served by
acquiring Riot games if they could have
forward them I think right is it with 10
cent or something I forget I don't know
yeah then we have Aaron Goldman with the
320 I did not sure what this is I
apologize look it up chances of rolling
factions into the last of us to uh
remaster or
three again if they go back and rework
it to that extent right where it is
something smaller than what it had been
sure that kind of makes sense yeah
potential there potential right that's a
possibility you know they got the move I
mean the next season I think the
remaster that they're going to do for
two which I'm not a fan of Jean I saw
your article but I respect expect your
opinion expect a different opinion but I
mean I get it it's it's going to sell
it's going to do well I it's going to do
well Crea bring it to PC finally right
because you they kind of do it together
yeah but I think they're going to line
that up with the with the movie I mean
with the um HBO and hopefully yeah
hopefully factions come back I do want
factions to come back man absolutely
because to me that thing is pretty done
abut it has to be close has to be a
playable product there shout out to my
man BG he goes so hard for factions and
I want him to get his F we need Sony to
make multiplayer games so I think the
pivot is correct you just need the
quality so we said it the pivot Jim made
the right move the move that nobody else
wanted to make atte that it's just it's
a matter of you know when you do that
you know the success rate right doesn't
matter if your PlayStation the success
rate is not good so you just got to Hope
that some of these hit right yeah no
absolutely it's it's a tough business
yeah then we have Nintendo daku $5 Super
Chat uh boohoo if these studios are
supposed to be the best they should be
versatile if the Animal Crossing devs
can make Splatoon there are no excuses
see but again we say that we don't know
if that the same exact devs that are
proficient at making Animal Crossing are
the same devs that are still on that
teammate Splatoon like it could be yes
100% mind you all of this happens in the
background too we are never privy to
what Nintendo's doing in the background
where we got no stitches over there yeah
yeah naughty naughty dog I'm sure
naughty dog would have loved to have
keep kept all of this under wrap that's
just not what happen right true so can't
make assumptions based on on stuff that
we I mean we can't which we do but again
we're assuming stuff we don't even know
again you know how you know how Nintendo
is they keep these guys in the dungeon
you're going to learn how to do this
shooting
game oh man that's it we're caught up we
caught up no doubt no doubt so oh is it
more than just gameplay it is he's on
his phone no doubt e holding us down
good to see him while we get he's
getting situated but uh Assa you want to
set this up man this is you we got uh
are we at the finish line or something
are we are we close oh yeah uh actually
actually our friend over at The Verge
Tom Warren indicated that Microsoft
could be eyeing to finally close it the
ABK deal this coming Friday Friday the
13th with a decision from uh the UK
regulator CMA eminent um but basically
everything is the road is open now for
this to happen uh specifically on Friday
is what people are assuming is is going
to be the deal um as we know like we you
know Microsoft and Activision sort of
extended the deadline deadline of the
deal to October 18th um and it seems
like they'll be able to come in you know
way ahead of that so we will see so if
this is the case right people are
excited right and as we were talking to
Paris about it for my question to you
guys is okay this happens Friday
obviously Phil said hey this is a this
is a ship that takes a while to turn
right this is not something that's going
to happen immediately but there could be
some lwh hanging fruit that they can
throw out there as a sort of like hey
this is just the tip of the iceberg what
we could do with all this IP so I want
to ask you guys first what do you think
is this is going to happen Friday and
secondly again any low hanging fruit
that they might give to the to the fans
out there like hey just you know can't
give you all of this stuff but you're
not getting Call of Duty today but you
can have here here's a little taste of
this right so if there's anything you
guys think can happen day one uh as sort
of a a little bit of a flex like hey we
own this now short of like showing the
moment that they you know they do the
the bank transfer of of Candy Crush to
Microsoft account the king money
transfers over the king money transfer
yeah that would be a mic drop moment in
it of itself but we got we got my man in
here man coat Eastwood more the game
playay one of the best first of all we
got to shout out the podcast too man we
got before this man is doing everything
now it's not just more than gameplay and
videos now you know what I'm saying we
got one of the top Xbox podcasts going
on how are you doing sir first let's see
how you sounding Out Here y yeah
hopefully everything's good I set it up
really quick uh you got me smooth on
smooth on the mic smooth on the mic
let's go um yeah I mean I don't have my
desk set up I'm I've I'm sitting here in
the track racer seat with the Logitech
g920 clutch shifter and and everything
so my camera's kind of far away but G
and I were planning on recording uh some
multiplayer Race together and kind of
producing some footage together give our
thoughts about the game and maybe uh you
know do what Gaz and I do and just be
clowns on camera so we're supposed to be
doing that sometime today but okay um
yeah yeah so quickly I mean I know
because Forza is the next time I want to
get your thoughts on Forza because I
know you've got a lot of thoughts there
but I did did quickly want to address
obviously what sa was talking about
which is could we potentially be this
close to ABK you know what are your
thoughts on it it's been a long journey
like where you at with this if this is
true the reporting my Tom yeah so it'll
be Friday the 13th and I think s's right
this this year's Call of Duty is a
throwaway for Xbox uh you know first
party uh you know celebration so I think
um early next year whatever ABK has in
the the release schedule early on when
that's all official but I think more
importantly than that uh hopefully Phil
and the team are working together like a
round table style thing like they did
with Bethesda where they're going to
gather some of the key leaders and talk
about what the future means with Xbox
and how they will be collaborating and
maybe shifting those Studios into do
something a little more than just being
the Call of Duty machine and I think
that's what most fans want to see most
of all so question is Bobby allowed to
to the cookout is he is he
allowed yeah I mean I was I was one
Randall thor9 I said hopefully they do
that round table and they're all sitting
there and Bobby's there and Phils like
welcome everybody Bobby uh thanks for
everything free to go to
uh actually it would be funny if they
did that just as a good nature joke but
he really did leave and uh and the
leadership that will be uh yeah they
exit him off they send him on his
way he's in the middle of eating one of
the free cookies that was on like the
little side
table I'm taking one of these with me
taking an extra cookie no doubt no doubt
final question before we move on I do
got to ask you a reference to this is um
what's the most if the deal goes down
all right what's the most exciting
aspect of the deal to you to personally
to Cole
Eastwood yeah cuz I don't care about the
all the extra money Xbox can make that
doesn't matter to me unless we start
hearing about what they're pumping into
that so uh we don't have anything yet
but I would like to hear if High Moon is
g to come back to form and they're gonna
build something or they or they start
working on a license deal with them
again like hey remember how you guys
knocked out of the park with the
Transformers license let's get that and
let's have you guys make a style
Transformers again and see if we can
reach that magic cuz I think um they
made three games that were in the
Transformers Universe and two of the
three were really good and so it's like
hey do you guys remember how to do that
that's that's that would excite me I'm
with you I'm with you l i mean Hasbro
wants it Lulu said the rumors of the
source code or whatever not existing for
the original is there so there's
interest I'm with you and shout out to
my man I'm going to sing his name his
Praises David Teague we have to free you
I know if you're in Call of Duty jail
wherever you're at in High Moon Studios
we need you you are the head leader on
the two games that are you know very
well-renowned and we we need you back
cuz you are a G1 head you understand
what Transformers Phil if you're
listening please someone find him get
this man a budget in a contract and
let's get him get this man of Shield get
this man of get this man of
shield no doubt I feel you calling that
no doubt adct the uh it's been what is
it 20 months almost man we've been
talking about it I remember when we did
that podcast with the
announcement right and it was just kind
of like yo can we believe this is
happening you know the rumors are saying
it's close you know what are your
thoughts
adct my thoughts is thank
God yeah even though that you know
what's funny is I'm sure C can uh speak
on this too it's for a community that be
claiming they don't want to hear about
Activision um Activision information
some of my best videos is ABK
really it would be the the most Littest
update people in the chat just sitting
there they they going crazy over it it's
like look it's been it's been a a
nightmare for a variety things you know
even content because there just be
talking about the same stuff but it's
just like man I just be glad when this
is over I really will you know let's
move this on to the next big publisher
they gonna buy oh you go better be you
better upet they going to get upset you
say that that's fine get upset you know
you can record me saying that so you can
play me every night before you go to bed
that's what it requires you to go to
sleep I'm okay so let me ask you this
though I know you don't care about Call
of Duty you probably do not care about m
is there anything about the deal that
Lord addict any game wise wow OverWatch
Diablo anything that interests you about
this nothing none of their games do
anything for you that's why when it was
announced I said I'm not going to lie
well [__] with
Sega say look this is good for their
bottom line and you know the only thing
that that I guess I would even care a
little bit it's like the Crash Bandicoot
franchise okay uh because I feel like I
don't care about the Crash Bandicoot
franchise I'm I'm I'm I'm hoping if they
actually generate money you know
somewhere along the lines there'll be a
banj Kazooie made right even though had
nothing do with ABK you just hear the
bar C but I got you no no no if they if
they start building on like a crash
franchise maybe if that picks up a
little bit they're like what else can we
do with similar types of ips it's just
like you
know I haven't played Call of Duty since
infinite Warfare really my brother's a
big fan of the zombies but he's a weirdo
so that doesn't count sh it's just I
just be glad when it's over he just want
it over that's my thing and you know not
to mention I I do like rubbing it in the
PlayStation Fanboy face too so you know
that's a good that's a plus isn't it you
know messy that's a plus I I just think
at the end of the day you
know if they actually take some of these
Studios that's this this sweat shop
working on Call of Duty wow if they take
some of these Studios and actually
generate different forms of ips then I'm
okay with that but I I don't think
they're doing that makes a lot of money
I think for the most part they're going
to be like we going to keep this well
going cuz we needed to generate that the
70.8 billion do back in some way shape
or form and I think Call of Duty's a
fantastic way of doing that I just want
I just want better for the industry you
know no doubt so I always so I always
said like people like well consolidation
is bad well what else was what's
Activision done they haven't really
innovated anything that uh if anything
they give us less IPS because they're
having everyone work on Call of Duty
it's like look I can't guarantee you
Microsoft's going to do any better they
might get in line do the same thing
Activision was doing in terms of game
development just because that's what
makes a lot of money but there's a
chance that say we don't need Call of
Duty every year let's let's let's free
up some of these Studios and have them
work on new IPS or you know bring stuff
like rare older IPS back we don't know
but you know what I do know Activision
wasn't changing that Activision was
going to stay in their ship because it
generated gold behind but at least now
we have a future that is unknown because
before we had a known future now we have
a future unknown that's fair that's fair
enough I'll jump in look we potentially
finally here right um I will say so
Friday the 13th would be hilarious yeah
if it actually closes and the
announcement was Friday the 13th that is
hilarious it's it's symbol symbolic on
many levels I don't think so hopefully
we get it you know at the earlier in the
week you you see like a little Tuesday
news drop little Tuesday Wednesday kind
of thing we'll see but um like Cole said
you know I just need that Xbox y post I
need that graphic and you see you know
the graphic code with all the studio
Xbox plus Activision Blizzard bro like
oh man like I it was it was very I
remember how joyous I felt when the
zamax won and because what it what the
reason why it was joyous is because you
start to realize the true impact when
you see every single studio and you go
wait a minute remember was like yo they
they have a Japanese studio now by proxy
they have too they have you know all
machine game you start to start to think
of the possibilities to addict's point
where I really agree with him is that
yes we are being you know Pine in the
sky you know hopefully you know the Call
of Duty train can stop you know being
annualized which we probably not going
to happen it makes too much money but
there is a hope because you see Phil
talk about classic IPS right and things
that could come back that they they want
to see so the hope is that yeah it might
not happen initially cuz we do we have
confirmed like the next three Call of
Duty games are kind of ready to go but
maybe that year four year five once
they've settled in maybe there's an
adjustment there but um look you know
this is one of those things that it
would be uh a major turning point in
gaming as far as the round table Co I
agree with you I would like to see you
know obviously Phil there Matt booty
greeny um I would like Mike Kara Rod
Ferguson you to stick around you two
gentlemen I think you guys have a you
know tremendous history obviously Mike
with Xbox he's been you know there from
you know day one again I know money is
involved things change you may Rod andar
G be like you guys yeah right you guys I
thought we got away from you said but
shout out to shout out to R because um
especially him you know he he's what I
consider the finisher you know what it's
gonna be you know the Spider-Man meeme
where it's the three
Spider-Man it's going to be Activision
Blizzard and Xbox all Point bro I would
love the reunion because again we've had
Cliffy be in the realm he has the
highest of respect for Rod Ferguson you
know his his his reputation in the
industry as someone who gets things done
the finisher of of some of the big
Blockbuster Games I think his Insight is
invaluable to the ABK de closing and
then the fact like you said like oh
there's that familiarity as former you
know Xbox employees they understand so
to me that makes the Synergy better you
know again it's their career though they
have to do what best for them I'm not
saying that they guaranteed they're
going to stay I mean it's different like
uh Ibara was is you know the master of
of Blizzard now you know when now when
he comes back to work under Phil on the
team you know he's like oh I'm coming
back home to what I kind of I feel like
iara kind of broke away so he could do
even more yes because he's very
ambitious very and he'll be and I'm sure
he'll be allowed to be the full master
of his team the way he's been doing um
under Xbox and I do expect Xbox to keep
the status quo on a lot of the ways that
um ABK will function but when you guys
are talking about the future of Call of
Duty and all the teams working on it
there has to be a little bit of guidance
where Xbox is going to say h how many of
you can we break away to create
something because a Call of Duty every
two years is not in the trajectory for
Game Pass but if you guys want to start
making other games smaller games and
some extra things to pep in between Call
of Duty's um frequency that's exactly
what we're looking for and some of the
you've got to know that hundreds of
those developers are like oh thank you
i' love anything but be the guy that or
the girl that makes all the trees in
the and yeah I mean that's what I'm
really looking forward to and we do like
adct you were saying it like we do hear
these this talk over the past 20 months
where Xbox has said we do want to do a
little bit more than what is done done
because adct nailed it we've seen less
franchises yes over the past 10 to 15
years since the Call of Duty machine has
become so powerful no I agreed and then
I think the initial short-term stuff
shout out to Paris who was here earlier
I agree wholehearted with what I how I
feel the integration is going to go you
know my prediction will be wrong I'll
take my L that I thought because I
thought the deal would be done earlier
Co so I like yeah so if I thought the
deal was done in like June July then I'm
like okay there's a strong chance that
this year's Call of Duty can end up in
Game Pass and I think that they would
have pushed that but being that it's
this late in the game and then you know
the marketing rights and all that I
think that will be the extent of it
it'll be like the marketing wres hey
Xbox is the home of Call of Duty not in
Game Pass but you'll see that marketing
I think it'd be smart for them to start
you know we saw the rumors about Black
Friday Series S you start to Market with
it and some you know get people the
Casual to know this is where you get it
um I think quot what you said I mean
what um sorry Paris said earlier about
um backward compatibility is very
accurate I think that they'll start
it'll be a slow tricker I don't think
we'll get all of it at the beginning
there'll be some maybe some select
titles and we've already SE engagement
for some of the older Call of Duties
right people you know wanting to play
that so I think we'll see that my
biggest question though is how the
blizzard inter and the King interaction
works because obviously you have wow you
know you have PC game pass you know
again Paris alluded to potential perks I
could see that you know it might not be
a full integration but Wow's a big deal
deal W was a big deal coming through you
know and being Affiliated they got to
deal with what they want to do with
blizzard on Console I mean hey you know
they you seen I mean I won't play it but
put it on I mean you've seen some you
know shout out to Jess Gordon Windows
Central there was some updates they're
making with controller as far as like
mapping and and and and extra
functionality jez has played a ton he
says controller integration would
absolutely work for classic wow and I
believe him so I've people say no but
jez plays it a lot look I mean it'll be
huge for them just for on PC and any
type of PC game pass integration if they
could somehow figure out console
integration oh boy that that that's a
game changer to get wow you know kind of
as the home or at least playable on Xbox
on a console form that would be sick and
yeah go ahead adct I'm sorry part of me
thinks that right now you know let's not
focus on that because that you know
Final Fantasy 14 is coming to the
platform and uh even though logistic
Minds it doesn't matter I want that I
want to do the best it possibly can do
and you know having something like wow
on there so wait wild can't be on it
what's this this biasness it's no it's
not biasness I just want that game to do
the best it possibly oh so you said
don't put wow here to kill my final
f is it is it going to like kill it no
but it's competition nevertheless it's
like I want more Final Fantasy games
I do think that they they not
necessarily will be look I mean you can
say it's I feel you being I love it I
love it you like K Chill on that this
Final Fantasy need to pop first and Y
take time this is the closest I've come
to maybe having like a Final Fantasy 7
remake on the platform I'd be damned if
like wow shows up W mess it
up like look look look at like something
like Destiny like we we don't have
enough time to play Destiny imagine like
if wow comes out before Final Fantasy 14
and they snatch half the console Market
with that thing and then when 14 drops
they're like oh I don't have time to
play two of these games this is this is
the one they can control though they're
both subscription services so it's like
you so 2010 15 20 30 like this stuff
adds up it's just like nah like I value
the Final Fantasy over anything so we
clearly see that you value because that
game could come anytime like
you know depending on how some of these
games do logistic wise on the platform
you is going to determine where Final
Fantasy is for the next couple years so
again Xbox executive leadership you've
heard it here first um slow down your
advancements on Wow Lord addict needs
Final Fantasy to 14 to thrive yeah I
need it to thrive I need to thri he
needs to that's his I actually want
these other square units games on the
platform shout out to my man Z dox in
the chat um yeah the final thing I was
just going to say is look you know I I
keep telling people the world out I've
been saying it for about a year and a
half even during the dark days when 2022
was light I said 2023 is going to be a
big year for them and so far it has been
right we've seen the games that are
coming out obviously Starfield for is
doing well um obviously high five rush
you know shout out to Red for which talk
about at least they added the 60 frags
they didn't give up on it we'll get into
that but they've had a great year so far
to me this is the cherry on the Sunday
the extra sauce that he wasn't sure was
going to happen but I said it happened
now you set up 2024 to be what I
consider the Avalanche because say what
you want you infuse all of these games
into the service think about we even
forgetting the power of Diablo
4 in Game Pass and again we assume a lot
of this stuff will be probably next year
right or the top of next year the final
lines and then you get that influ of
back compack and then you get Call of
Duty Mainline call of listen I haven't
played Call of Duty in a minute but I'm
going to tell you right now 399 in game
pass your boy Sal play it free that's
nice your boy will be seeing how that
Prestige will be doing cuz I just want
to see because I I have I would never
listen that's my back in my old days I
was never paying $70 now to do none of
that that's the young that's a young
man's game I recognize where I'm at my
twitch skills is garbage my fast twitch
but you going to tell me hey campaign
and a new joint every year of course all
I got to do is just boot it up it's on
my screen like of course so I think that
that's huge so and this that's the
interesting thing because Call of Duty
die hards are not loyal to a piece of
plastic they're loyal to their friends
all playing Call of Duty with it being
cross platform play when they start
getting the that they be a to get that
game for like pay $20 to pay it play it
non-stop for two months or three months
for 30 bucks uh on Xbox game pass on PC
or console or whatever they want like
they're gonna there's going to be a big
surge of Game Pass Subs that's what
they've been waiting for Absol
absolutely 100% agree so yeah that's
pretty much where I'm at hopefully we
are at the Finish Line any other
thoughts before we move on sa this was
yours uh tenu please oh tenu yes yes
give me tenu yes give me T at least give
me the back compact joints um yeah yeah
give me give me give me some of that
let's go in the Legacy the Legacy games
there were a couple of 102 games that
were PlayStation 2 only that were really
good yes yes so H yeah I just I want
that stuff Lulu
finu we got to get the source C so we
are good let's get the Super Chat
mooving because I gotta get C on on this
uh we got one more we have one we have
uh Angry hippie $2 Super Chat Warcraft
one through3 on Console please yeah we
forgot about core Warcraft core
Starcraft yeah br br we're forgetting
about this Library we only see Call of
Duty right and we think is it's a huge
liary completely agree that was it
that's it all right let's get into attic
I need a favorite cuz we got Co here
just want to switch to order I know we
going to do AC Mirage and Forza but I
want to ask Co East because he's sitting
in the fly chair right now you know what
I'm saying he's driving he's hitting the
corners I see I was getting sweaty in
this I see them putting the clips up you
know I had some fora experiences in real
life with Co we go get yeah we had some
driving experiences that we you know out
there in Seattle we going to get into
but uh we we were drifting the parking
gar we definitely drifted in the indoor
parking lot try to escape so all good
but um yeah let's talk about it you know
obviously you know it's out the reviews
are out you know it's been some feedback
you know what's your experience been how
are you feeling about fora Motorsport
right now um okay let me get some of the
things out of the way like the campaign
just does one thing and that's it okay
it's the Builder cup it puts you in a
car um with you know a stock car and you
put a few upgrades in in it typically
five to six upgrade segments uh as you
do four to five races in the series the
series is over and then they put you in
different discipline and you slowly work
your way up from uh like hatchbacks or
you know kind of modern coups and sedans
up into toward the racing cars and then
that's it it's a it's a one note one
note game mostly throughout the
experience with the campaign uh it
doesn't have any I mean it's there's a
lot I could get into that it could do
but that's it's still really solid
though you get you get into this Rhythm
I was just doing a early 80s hatchback
thing there's like the Volkswagen scarco
and I'm driving some car called the
Dodge Shelby which is just a boxy
hatchback but it has a cool feeling and
um and then you'll work your way into
the Porsches and the Audi and stuff like
that so it's a really great feeling
racer just I can feel the actual weight
of every car the the labor of the brake
on on corners and apexes and and
throttling and downshifting and all that
stuff's really great the game got a
really bad WP for how it looked out the
gate and I think the narrative has
really changed like hold on I think
forts of Motorsport looks really great
turn 10 needs to make some tweaks and I
guess I'd rather have you ask me some
questions because otherwise I would I
got questions the in the seat in the
seat you're in the hot seat you're legit
in in the driver's Hot Seat no I guess
you know so you mention obviously you
know there was I think digital Foundry
had something initially about you know
maybe the lighting right in the daytime
or something like that and then to your
point we're starting to see you even put
up footage of of like driving at night
driving in the rain which looked
phenomenal right and then so the
question I have is that you know as far
as the look at the game the you know any
little controversy regard that to you
know as a steering wheel driver you know
how do you feel about about the control
the basic physics the driving of the
game and then the last casting is
probably the what I consider a
controversy is the way the the RP the
car RPG sensibilities right like oh yeah
yeah that that I see some push back
there's three things you're asking me
there and since I kind of talked about
the feel I'll just say really quickly
the feel on a controller is awesome the
feel on a
$300 prer consumer like the Logitech
steering wheel or if you get like the uh
uh the the thrustmaster like those are
$300 or whatever that feels great and
you know you need to buy a thousand
wheel like Forza Irwin will tell you oh
yeah shout to for they got a great video
yeah and he's amazing he has both so he
knows but if you want to play at the
wheel like if you spend the $250 or $300
you're gonna have such a realistic great
experience um the other thing you asked
me about I have to cover first is the
lighting thing turn 10 needs to fix they
have like some kind of I'm not going to
talk about the gamma bug because that's
already patched out but there's a gamma
problem with the game when you drive
into direct sunlight you know like when
you're coming home from work and the Sun
is like right under your visor and
you're like I can't see the sun is not
orange orangish yellow it is this
desaturated pale yellow like a it's this
color that is just not what you see
every day I'm I'm 70 years old I know
what the Sun looks like when I drive
home it is a bright yellow with with
orange overtones in the game it is this
mrid translucent yellow or orange um
that is not bright enough not strong
enough not saturated I'm really big into
photography videography but you if you
have a pair of eyes and You' paid
attention outside you touch grass you
know what the Sun looks like and it's
like it's like they took it they're like
oh we don't want to Blind him so we're
going to turn down the contrast and it
just doesn't look natural and it's a the
other problem is I think the art
director team said let's dial back the
saturation the color so it they kind of
decolor the game because they feel like
this is more realistic but I'm out every
day walking with my wife and I'm like
the world looks like this amount of
color 115% this is what the color looks
like because my even my OLED uh at the
at the at the middle point I'm up like
10 points out of 100 because that's what
the world looks like I see it every day
I would yeah if you have an LG OLED I
would recommend put the color up just a
little bit just a little bit okay okay
gang I'm going on a silt box but I know
that people are like why does it look
washed out why does it look like this
why does it look flat and I think the
turn 10 made a constant decision I think
it looks I think it looks more realistic
when you pull the color out and I'm like
no turn 10 it doesn't make Patch It Up
Patch It Up fix it bring the color back
up and and crunch the contrast just a
little bit and that's why gt7 looks
better in the side by sides because GT
is over gt7 is way oversaturated like
almost a little too much but I like that
so not that's just color they went they
went with that that choice that there is
some push back there as far as again the
car RPG the carg yeah I was going to ask
about that so I'm not a good person to
give you a good solid like my honest
opinion complain about it because when I
play for the Forza Motorsport games I go
through the disciplines I try to get top
Podium I make a couple of adjustments I
don't modify my cars that's what I do in
Horizon but I feel like the rhythm of
fors and Motorsports always been get in
the seat uh race and try to get to the
top and so I understand the complaints
uh that it takes like 10 hours or three
I think I think takes three hours of
racing one car to get it up to level 50
and yes somebody was asking I do almost
all of the full practices all three laps
and all that before I do the race um I
don't know why I just feel like I'm
robbing myself of an experience if I
don't um
but hiding some of
the upgrades behind how long you drive
the car is a cool concept but they need
to dial that way back down okay so just
a little too aggressive with you know
because I remember we were out there and
I was me and King and and we we were at
the forza event and the thought process
was kind of like you know we want you
this is not for Horizon they say we not
for Horizon but they they would
basically say we don't want this to be a
car collection game right we want you to
have this you know they referen their
their last games where they just give
you a Porsche and a hurricane right one
after the other go ahead right no no
yeah absolutely right and instead they
said hey we want you to have this
relationship with this car and then you
kind of build it you know you level up
before you you go on to the next but to
your point maybe it was a little too
aggressive you know what I'm saying yeah
maybe can dial that back a bit uh I was
in a different segment uh when Chris
Zaki and Dan gwall were showing us the
game in the behind the scenes things in
LA and Chris suzaki was sitting there
and there's only like eight of us in the
room content creators and journalists
and he goes we want you to fall in love
with the Honda Civic and I go I love
Honda C he because I do I love cars like
that and he says we want you to fall in
love it's like but yeah car car guys we
love a car like we love to take uh
Angley Bowden said that he loves to take
to buy the car that he actually owns and
get it all the way up to the things that
he's done to it in real life and he said
I got to grind that car for several
hours to be able to do that and I'm like
well Angy you had to grind for several
several years and make the money make
money I mean it is what it is but no
that they need to dial back the the time
it takes or else people are going to get
mad no that's fair that's fair sofp we
got a couple super chats that are
speciic this so we got a PK Thunder whoa
$50 Super Chat thank you appreciate that
thank you brother speaking about force
of motor support I'm actually pretty
shocked that when talking in in depth
about these new games you guys have a
talking point
damn appreciate you appreciate
you I'm playing Forza right now and
y'all are not talking about what happens
when you get a penalty so oh okay I love
that I love I love it
yeah go for it um it the
penalty uh there were times when I would
use one of the cars as a as a as a
jersey barrier oops I took this turn too
hot and uh thank you forrar you're going
to be my bumper my Lane bumper like
bowling um the penalty system is really
smart it decides that if it was you
being aggressive or if it was just it
even says if that it even kind of says
in the background the AI is saying it's
the nature of that what happened in that
moment and no one gets a penalty but if
you're aggressive it's like hey we see
it and we're giving you a half a second
on your lap time and what it does is
it's going to keep people in the
multiplayer from just slamming everyone
or push them into the grass but it also
just get you're in the moment you don't
want to scratch your car you don't want
to scratch someone else's car you want
to make a smart breaking decision whip
around wide on the outside or take that
like really uh aggressive move on the
inside when it's right without bumping
somebody and the penalty system and it
cranks up at the top and it's like we're
deciding I love the penalty system yeah
no absolutely happily agree what was the
other Super Chat s the other one is more
just uh it's PK Thunder wo again $10
chat I've noticed that when they
compared Forza 7 to the new Forza
visually Forza 7 looks better than the
new Forza but when you play the new
Forza it is the opposite so I guess when
they compared it in videos it seemed
like the old Forza look better and then
when you look at the yeah
and no he's saying that he apparently
saying that that when playing it proper
the opposite is
true yeah the new one feels better but
you just cannot take away how great fors
of7 looks okay because on Xbox One X and
the new Xbox seriesx that game runs at
Native 4K 60 so you don't have any
ambient inclusion on the old one but you
know what what turn 10 does is they have
to make up for uh not having real real
lighting so they try and make realistic
lighting and I always think that's a
great formula for a greatl looking game
because we've been seeing that for 15
years where devs are like look we can't
do the realistic we can't do raay
tracing we got to make it look like it's
real and I think they usually end up
making games look phenomenal because
they're fine-tuning it by hand no doubt
Lord addict you um the hardcore racing
guy that you are um you got to
review of for what what your thoughts
sir H I went into this people are like
addict the Forza Horizon that's the
Casual game Forza more sports that's
like the serious tone I'm like bet let's
try it uh so I went in there acting like
I was playing for of
Horizon and uh look you know it's cool
that you know that they tell me when I
hit someone they're like you know you're
getting penalized uh they're telling me
you know we're gonna put time on your
laugh I'm like I don't care about none
of that so that think that plus 10
irrelevant because I'm not looking at
that time at the end of the MTH it's
like all I'm looking at is me number one
okay it do matter how I get there it do
matter who I hit it matter who I use as
a barrier to stop me from going 80 to 10
it's like all that matters is at the end
winning is
winning in or mile we know what your
safety rating is yes yeah I don't even I
don't even and then you know not to
mention you know let's say that
um my my driving gets so bad
where I start spinning out of
control you know Forza gave me a tool
it's called rewind shout out to rewind
shout out to rewind W rewind that's all
I had to do man anytime something's
going bad
rewind anytime I feel like I can't go
from 80 to 10 hit someone else like look
I think logistic wise this game
definitely demands you play this like a
like a legit racer but I don't want
people thinking that you can't play this
game is just like a racing game because
I was doing like those 24 man races like
all the time and I especially on normal
you know I'm playing against the little
timmies I ain't playing against the big
Timmy salute so it's just see play some
bumper cars some rewind the
VHS time I don't know nothing about the
cars I don't know nothing about you know
what's funny is I said in the review and
people were make uh people were laugh
laughing they're like they're cuz I said
you know I know what a Mustang is and a
charger is kind of like a Mustang I
guess and people are laughing at close
it up yeah I enjoyed it I enjoyed it I
thought I thought it was a fun
experience you know I'd never play this
online I wouldn't even go touch I
wouldn't even I wouldn't even go if they
say go outside it's great out I'm good
in here you know I I like playing the
little timmies I'm not going to go play
his older brother outside I feel you
look I I I I like playing
the the AI that knows I'm going hit
Himi is really smart if if I play Colt
he knows it's coming he gonna break we
ain't doing that I've seen I've seen
addict's dyar But the dyars are really
just their new AI system yes so they're
not I don't even think they they run off
of your behavior they've just kind of
tuned them to try and be like real
drivers unless mine is violently going
through the track and not care about no
one's Heth health or car health is not
driving like I drive I drive fast than
the Furious hit the break as least as I
can all I know is addict and Randall
Thor in my rearview that's really all
that that's what I all about it back it
back who in my game you ain't even there
C
because damn no no no we got we
appreciate the uh the the Insight yeah
it it was it was fun you know my funny
is my girl came over and she saw me
right I don't know what vehicle it was I
don't I'm not a vehicle person and uh I
don't even like driving in real life you
don't even know what car she was in so
she comes in there she's like she says
something she's oh that's cool I didn't
know you like those cars I'm like I
guess he even know he was in this is the
car it gave to me I cannot with him he
is out of control but I respect it I
respect it so uh fellow car Enthusiast
fishing AO uh your thoughts or you get a
chance to rock this yet okay right it
comes out when do it come out Tuesday
off for peons yes wait it's not even out
yet no yeah technically this is just the
early I could have got ear talking like
this game's been out yeah like it's out
for year like the world got play forun
anymore it's it's that early access just
put another layer on
stuff yes yes yes so it's it's not
officially out in Game Pass proper until
uh Tuesday I think um yes so that's when
I will play it cuz again I am not that
good I will play I will pay for Early
Access to Horizon but not this cuz I
know I know my limit spoilers CU you
said not out spoilers C is hilarious I
know my limits but again it's it looks
pretty I I'm interested to see into the
look into the car PG stuff right because
this is something new for them yeah and
uh yeah so I'm just I'm interested to
see it and on the PC compare it
to compare it to
the build you I ran it on the window
store it ran really good like really
really good okay because I have three
points of comparison I have the NZXT
build I have the 4090 build and I have
the console so it's like okay yeah I
I'll make that comparison and see but
again I I I know the console stuff is
you know they worked hard on it so I
really do want to see that same way like
I downloaded we'll talk about a little
bit I I didn't get a chance to play
redfall again but I downloaded I had it
running a 60 on the PC that wasn't the
problem for the game on all around it's
just a matter of seeing it at 60 on the
console is what I wanted to see so yeah
I I'm excited to talk about it when I
actually get a chance to play and I
heard yes uh again this spoilers I think
it runs pretty well on the Ally
so yeah allly ran um Horizon games
amazing so I would yeah I would be
impressed I'll jump in um look you know
kind of it's one of those things that
again I Come From You Know The Horizon
background I'm not the simulation guy so
you know when I went to try it you know
my thing is I was kind of surprised at
how much I was getting into it and I
think like I said doing the you know the
qualifying laps the open practice and
the game consistently giving me that
positive reinforcement when you did
second to the track well and it's like
hey you improved the time there and you
seeing the levels up going up I ain't
never listened more in a video game in
my whole life it was like slowed down
I'm like oh yes sir I was hugging that I
have my I listen I'm casual car on this
I have my little assistant that's
telling me that racing
it was like all right you got yeah it
was with it bright red slow down brother
I was I was monitoring that joint making
sure I stay in Pocket trying to race
clean but up to Colts point you know the
thing that I really loved and again
getting a chance to interview you know
creative director Chris aaki from turn
10 and awesome he's amazing and the
thing that really cuz I remember there
were certain parts I'm like yo I'm
trying to race clean cuz you know how it
is in the first part of it soon as the
the the race starts is that pile up that
starts with the first turn and classic
Cog you know you you kind of bully
balling you you kind of rubbing
shoulders and I'm like nah I'm not going
to do this this Motorsport we got to we
got to race to be fair though that that
stretch is how I get to like third place
right
off cuz you know old school it doesn't
matter if I if I if I cause eight nine
and 10 to split out of control I it
matters where I am so it's like usually
it's the cheat where you cut the corner
and you try to jump ahead or you just
you know you bump a car your way through
whoever catch the raft catch the raft as
long as you get to the third that's
usually old school right so I'm like nah
you can't play like this this is bis
sport this simulation you got to you got
to be real so I'm driving clean as best
I can there was a couple times where
it's clear you know AI is getting into
my vicinity I'm like yo I'm not trying
to hit him no no no and then boom the
Collision does happen and like you said
Co you see the game at the top you see
it says collision and you see the game
almost stinking for a couple of seconds
right and then at that point you get the
decision penalty no penalty when they
shave time off but a lot of times I
wasn't getting no penalty I remember
asking Chris about this and he was
telling me yo that's the machine
learning cuz what's happening is at the
point of collision the 15 seconds after
what happens and the 15 seconds before
it's what's being analyzed and then
they'll determine okay yeah that's
that's whether or not it's in the realm
of clean racing that was an accident now
there was a couple times called where I
tried my adct tactics my bully boy
tactics you know posting up someone put
the emote going like this and they're
saying me watching adct
RAC yeah and there a couple times where
it was me and the gay correctly was like
yeah bro that's you we gonna shave that
time off yeah it's cool cuz like in you
know with a lot of physics you know you
could say he hit me but the if it you're
saying it's looking back 15 seconds
before before the collision and after
and it's like because Cog you got into
this position you know like you're in
their driving line or you're you're
creeping into the Apex and you're you
know they had nowhere to go they were
you know because if that car is the car
wants to go in a straight line and
they're trying to make that curve around
you smash him on the uh on the inside
yeah it's really really cool and I have
to say that when a simulation racer can
seem very boring like why you know oh I
don't like that type of game but once
this game is giving you so much
immersion yes where you like when I'm
driving even if I'm not on the even I'm
on a controller like when I get in I
creep up and the car is like right here
and I'm trying to scoot by him like and
I and my shoulder is physically even on
the controller my shoulder's like tou
that being in the moment is all these
things with the sense of speed that make
you appreciate yes why people like Sim
Racers and you may not love it you may
not play forever but when you get that
feeling and you get that sense of speed
and you overtake somebody on the outside
which is very difficult because you have
more speed and you're like that was
really cool in those moments you can
understand and respect Absolut Sim racer
and it's kind of like with with flight
Sim like why would you want to play that
then you get these moments you're like
oh I see why people love this and it
incentivized me to do better you know
what I'm saying and I love like I said
you got the racing met you got the your
skill level and you got your safety R
and then look if they they you know too
many addicts around it they going to put
him in that class that safety you know
level put him in the penalty Bo Penalty
Box class and he could race he could
race with his kind I got no problem
playing Forza card exactly Forza card
you know what I'm saying but I just want
to shout out him on that I did want to
shout out um look I know the looks have
been you know on some of the lighting
stuff totally here when you say Co I
will say though when I'm seeing this
rain footage I have not seen no racing
game look like that when you seeing like
when they showing the rain and the wet
track and you seeing the hood of the car
and the reflections and the thing and
and and just how slick the track looks
I've never like the game in the rain is
phenomenal looking it really is a
showcase and you know look they they
they got to put out obviously we know
there's going to be this is a platform
that's supposed to going to continue to
improve it give tracks out and stuff
like that hopefully the cool thing about
it being a platforms maybe they can
address what you said about the kpg and
and lightening up the restrictions there
yeah these are Chang that hopefully that
turn 10 will continue to go I still want
that spectator mode though we got to get
in spectator mode but other than that no
I'm hearing that look at the end of the
day people are loving this game they say
the physics are great and it drives well
and it's a substantial improvement over
seven in terms of the way it drives and
especially steering wheel support which
I was heard was also overed because
Chris isaki told us that you know I
think last time last last for was like
you were at a disadvantage using a wheel
you know what I'm saying versus a
controller player yeah and now
it it does that so that's good to see
but that that's pretty yeah you can use
a steering wheel and you'll be like uh
in 10th Place yeah on the old one yeah
yeah because it's and it's even like
that on fors rizon 5 I I have to put the
game down on an easier mode but right
now I'm playing no HUD no driving line
no tachometer I have to listen I've got
my headphones on I have to listen to the
engine before I upshift or downshift and
uh it's gotten to that point um
also what adate I'll say this about
I'm playing with the trail automat I got
every assist on bro don't worry adct I'm
with you we got every assist continue Co
um like for of Irwin sent me screenshots
of moving the sliders like the opposite
direction to get the wheel to feel
proper and and when I loaded up the the
retail release version I didn't mess
with it yet I'm like see how it is I'm
like oh this is good I'm leaving it I
haven't even asked him like so yeah it's
that's whatever but as far as them
changing the amount of time it takes to
level up a car uh and like and fixing
the gamma and the color or the contrast
situation they need to get on that stuff
and not think oh well we're going to do
season two in in May next year like
point no like get the like uh cyber Punk
already had a 2.01 patch yes like the
other day I've been playing that like a
ton and it's just great to see the teams
go look we can do it we a little more
that's just going to make it just a
little more smooth absolutely send out
the patch get it certified and people
are happy absolutely and hopefully like
I said the hope is that with it now
being a platform for the gener that they
will be consistent with the updates
consistent with that kind of stuff and
address that like you said in a smaller
patch and shout out to ebontis he I saw
he reviewed it as well he's get your
steering wheel bro because I see you see
my man called out here he he's tempted
he's like damn I want that steering
wheel he want to do it so salute to him
but I do want to Pivot um adct I mean
actually this is um you as well in
reference to Assassin's Creed cuz this
uh barrage also came out this week so
obviously your thoughts on it you've
been playing it you know where you at
man Assassin's Creed
Mirage all right
so I see a lot of people where like
they've scored this game it's like a
sitting at like a 70 something on
Metacritic I feel them on that when I'm
reading a lot of the reviews and
watching the reviews you know I'm just
tempted like were the fans of the
previous you know
assassin's yeah I feel like we got a lot
of people that started with like origin
Odyssey or vanala probably Odyssey
because Odyssey I think was the better
one of those three and it's just like
Mirage was made because Ubisoft got
tired of people saying I want the old
Assassin's Creed back look I will agree
with
you they they say they're like oh you
guys want assassins we're going to give
you exactly you going to get that
experience 100% old school they they
it's like that Calvin moment where
they're in there the last person like
can we improved the old system and they
threw him out the
window this is the definition of old
Assassin's Creed okay you know where you
you're you're ease dropping on people
you know when I actually kill people
they die now no what what I like is they
actually do have certain um you know ads
or you know certain guards they have
like a a yellow bar and some of them
can't be killed with one hit like like
an assassination yes so that's cool like
I do agree with some of the criticism
that it does feel repetitive but here's
the thing that's what the majority of
the people that wanted old Assassin's
Creed they wanted that that formula that
the old Assassin's Creed had you know I
will
agree it should have been improved on I
I don't think they really improved on
anything in terms of the core aspects of
the old Assassin's Creed um you know I
think this is more of a side project for
them they're like okay you those 10 go
use that closet and make an Assassin's
Creed back in the old days you know I I
don't think this is something that
they're really focusing on because you
could tell takes like 13 15 hours to
beat uh so and and you you could argue
maybe that price wasn't the right for
that type of experience you know I'd
argue if you have a good well- told
story with a lot of uh you know with a
lot of fruit in the in in the narrative
then you could charge that 70 but I I
see a lot of people that's like you're
trying to essentially charg me more
money for a game that was made in the
early
2000s uh so I feel them on that I still
think Syndicate was one of the best like
like Assassin's Creed 2 black Flack and
syndicate's like the three the the three
you know gold silver and bronze ones
when it comes to that so I I think think
but when it comes to Assassin's Creed
Mirage yes if you like those old
Assassin's Creed games oh it's $50 it's
not 70 okay okay okay I think we should
mention shout out to
Ubisoft yes yes Ubisoft gave us Cod
that's what shout for providing the
review code for for we have to play yeah
I'm I'm gonna be 100% real with you guys
I ain't looked at a price on a game in a
minute unless I tell Sol to S
it that's right I am you for $50 I I see
that that that that's solid solid you
know and it just to to it's what you
want if you want the older Assassin's
Creeds then we got a game for
you you want the newer RPG style
Assassin's Creeds we also got games for
you and and what I find hilarious is
this is why being a publisher and a
developer sucks we had for like a decade
people are like this is cool orins is
cool odyssey's cool Valla is cool but I
miss old Assassin's Creed and UB saw
okay here's old Assassin's Creed this is
too much like the old Assassin's Creed
like and I saw they put out this road
map they said hey we're going to make an
old one we're going to make the the last
last uh generation one or the I don't
know what you call it we're going to
make the open one we're going to make
the classic we're going to make one
that's a little bit different like they
they announced three different types yes
of Assassin's Creeds which is so weird
like no no Studio or publishing team has
ever done that like Hey we're gonna do
this with the franchise over the next
eight years or whatever that was kind of
a weird announcement it was interesting
it must be for a big reason they must
have because Assassin's Creed is one of
the biggest gaming franchises in the
world and people don't realize it and
they're like we don't want to lose this
divisive fan base that's split so we're
going to do our I love Ubisoft so much
and shout out to them for sending me the
crew Motorsport which is
fantastic sending assassin cre Mirage
which I started yet I love that team
because they do so they do so much fan
service they try so hard to appease such
a wide audience and the best of their
ability I will say this it's not even a
fan service like in terms of like
content creation like they could be like
they could have the worst game in the
world and they're you I've never felt
like Ubisoft is withhold stuff for in
any account they're like well go ahead
you know we might we might regret this
but play it tell us what you think like
I gotta respect it because in in a day
and age where PR is very very calculated
it feels like the pr over there
ubisoft's like look we gave you a
product we're going to give you the
product and you give us your honest
opinion that's literally every encounter
I've ever had of Ubisoft has went that
direction here's the product tell me
when you have the the coverage good or
bad we're never even going to even
remotely hit towards we didn't like the
way you perceived that and there's been
games that we've went went in on with
Ubisoft and they never have slided away
from giving us access to their games oh
you implying that others might feel away
if you said negative oh yeah I do I
definitely you know that that's that's
why I feel like you you know what
exactly s you wanted to say something
then Co finish Co no co co finish your
point then I'll jump in yes Co you were
saying I say cream I don't know I just I
know I'm just I people give Ubisoft a
hard time but I just really respect that
they try all these things they make like
really ambitious games that don't always
like become Masterpiece or almost never
do but I just have a big respect for
them and they do try and support their
Games host I I heard that they did a
bunch of stuff to Valhalla they changed
camera angles they let you do different
things with the difficulty um because I
kind of have 200 hours and I gave up on
it uh but yeah they they just continue
to improve and we're this is like the
new theme in the games development where
like we're not going to give up on our
games it's like where it Segways into
the next
game like so perfectly right yeah no we
definitely def segue into that in a
minute I just want to get some thoughts
on Mirage he is the resident Assassin's
Creed Lord he always gives me crap about
my love for Ghost and what The Who The
champ is and you know Mar out here going
back to your MK and murder sensibilities
how we feeling about this um I just to
address point I love them too all right
I love them too and they do take these
chances you know who the heck is going
to support for Honor for like five years
or whatever so but I do think them doing
taking this sort of new Cadence with
Assassin's Creed is just money related
it's just like like okay how do we
appeal to every like every assassin
possible so we're to do what Call of
Duty does we're just going to give you a
different type of Assassin's Creed game
every year so we can go back to the year
we
call we call it dying it with different
types of Assassin's Creed games so
everybody gets appeased right and kind
of it's kind of what I think they want
to do because I I know they weren't
happy having to sort of cut down on the
Cadence the yearly Cadence Assassin's
Creed right great analogy so I to me
this is their way of doing that while
appealing to everybody right so I've
only gotten to play like a little bit of
this like five hours um and what I can
get from it so far is that it goes back
but it goes back to a fault where it's
like okay you're not taking any of the
lessons you learned since then and
applying them to this formula it seems
like right again I haven't played that
much but it just sort of feels like okay
this is what it was back then we're GNA
make it a little cleaner right we know
what we're doing we it's going to look a
little bit better um the Anvil engine is
getting old um to me it just feels like
they went back and they and they were
safe in that regard where it's like hey
you know none of the stuff that we
learned in subsequent the RPG style
Assassin's Creed games we're going to
apply to this we're just G to go back
and this is what it's going to be this
is this is the lane for this right and
that was again I haven't played that
much to know if they expand later on but
it does sort of feel like they went back
to that and that's it yeah um because
again I go through the tutorial like all
right this is pretty simplistic this is
like there's no skill tree here there's
no sort of like you know it it there's
there's stuff where I expected more
depth okay um and them sort of expanding
on a little bit of the traversal stuff
like obviously they go back to this to
this sort of traversal where it's not
you're not Spider-Man you can't climb on
everything everything has a path right
but you know give me instead of doing
that you could have done what you did
with Revelations with Revelations they
gave you like a like a hook that you can
jump onto you can you can expand the way
you climb by jumping up up up a wall and
like hooking onto something things like
that I'm like okay use the technology at
hand to improve that somewhat while
still while it's still not being you
know AC Odyssey AC you know Origins
where you're just climbing on everything
and it just didn't do that right
um so in terms of combat just the little
training stuff that I've done in combat
so far again very simplistic in term but
I kind of like that like if you go back
to ac2 AC Brotherhood and
Revelations you have this whole thing
where you're you it's all about the
Parry right it's about the you waiting
the Parry so that you can open up uh
sort of cool death animation and that's
pretty much what it is um so I've done a
little bit of that and that feels cool
but it's not super indepth it's all
about like looking for the Parry uh
looking for the Tells like the you know
they turn red when it's it's an
unblockable move you just get out the
way stuff like that
um tell me that there wasn't a lot of
for Honor features in this game to a
degree like when I was fighting those
big dudes with the axes I'm like man did
they don't tell me they ripped this
straight from 400 that's another thing s
you know a lot of people are complaining
that you can't just go through this game
and kill a bunch of
people yeah you're not you're you're
kind of weak in that regard he's not a
fighter right idea assass right idea and
that that is one thing I have to give
them when you go back to original
Assassin's Creed uh you know it is about
it is about you figuring out the best
way to assassinate these targets and the
the reality of it is that when you
assassinate a Target like if you step up
behind them and you put that your hidden
blade into their chest and their neck or
whatever they're dead it doesn't matter
who they are it doesn't matter how
powerful quotequote powerful they are
you didn't have you didn't have you know
power meters and bars above them it's
about how you how you execute the the
the the
assassination here they one of the
things they did kind of with the middle
ground where it's like okay you have you
have these uh Whatchamacallit these
guards that do have a power meter above
them whatever and you know you'll have
to whittle it down for some of these
guys but when it comes to I have a
Target I have to assassinate if you are
able to get behind them sneak in behind
them and kill
you kill him and that's it there's no oh
you stab me once I'm turning around
turns into this turns into this fight
yeah it's hand in hand you know what's
funny s you know a lot of people like to
call like Ubisoft the copy and paste and
they do uh to a huge degree but like I I
I love the fact that they they found an
audience and they're like look like
we'll inate certain aspects of their
games but it's like but we know what our
fan base wants we know what type of
content they want we're not going to
change it drastically because we know
some people are going to be upset it's
like it's like the Final Fantasy in
squareenix you know they would have had
that mindset they would perhaps be at
their persona but it's like no it's like
people like Assassin's Creeds for a b
and c is there be people com you be
people on like the far right that's like
put dcna a in there like but I will say
this though went I I give the whole part
about copy and pasting when it comes to
systems and combat and whatever from
game to game there's some improvements
and some changes but it's not really
that right but I what I do give them
props for is the worlds that they create
Baghdad in this game is absolutely
there's a moment when when we first
start the game baddad looked great right
Beautiful Mind you I'm playing it on the
I'm playing it on the the the
Whatchamacallit the um NZXT NZXT AMD
Edition wow I have everything on ultra
settings with FSR 2 on it is a beautiful
it's a beautiful side to behold now
early on the game looks cool it looks
great like it looks very nice but not
until you return and that's all I'm
going to say not SP there's a point
where you come back to Baghdad and
you're standing in the desert and you're
looking out over Baghdad you're like oh
okay like I'm I'm I'm creating tracks in
the sand with my feet and the HDR is
popping and the like the the the redness
and orangeness of the sun is is sort of
it's a beautiful thing to see so the
game is is G gorgeous in Parts um but I
will say that their worlds are something
special is one of the criticisms in kog
is not going to like this but I I had of
of sushima where sushima is beautiful
right and every the rain you feel like
you're on like an island in Japan you
really do but the detail with which they
craft these worlds in Assassin's Creed
to me kind of takes it to the next level
where it's you know they try to be
historically accurate about about things
and it's and and again the further on we
get in technology those places are going
to look more and more beautiful which is
why I think they need to sort of evolve
from the Anvil engine the faces kind of
look the same like it really does look
like an upres 360 game in FA facial
animations and stuff like that um so
that's as much as I can say about the
game so far I will talk more in depth
about the the gameplay and the systems
once I've had more time with it but so
far it is scratching that itch it's like
oh they went back to it okay I I'm happy
but at the same time I'm a little
disappointed cuz I wanted them to evolve
the form I wanted them to go back to it
and be like hey how do we take these old
things and improve upon them right I
still haven't seen you know back I love
the original Assassin's Creed where you
could you know you you were basically
yeah you you you know the the social
stealth where you're following your
Target and you're listening to
conversations and stuff like that I
don't know if they brought that back
here I I hope they have but I don't know
that they've done that and that was
something that they kind of removed from
Assassin's Creed too rather than evolve
it they said no we're going to take this
away right right and my thing is go back
to it and see hey can with the tech we
have now can we make this work right and
it doesn't feel like that's the case so
I'm a little disappointed in that regard
but again I'm glad to have this type of
AC back I don't like Colt said
yo it Valhalla is intimidating to even
like you open up that map and it's like
are you are you really even if you want
to beine the story it's a it's a 100
hour investment like it's crazy
so you could tell me I can do everything
in this game in 30 hours that's
fantastic I'm happy with that I already
show actually 15 20 is what I'm hearing
exact Well yeah if you really be lying
it for sure 100% no I jump in I'm got
too much I'm in the same kind of b as
you saw where again did prolog and maybe
got three or four hours afterwards after
that you know look I think what you said
s is the Perfect Analogy When you
mention Call of Duty in it sense
of I'm going be real with y'all you know
what I'm saying like this new world of
assassin assin Creed I have not played
an Assassin's Creed new line joint I
done not like for a minute I've
completely disconnected from the
franchise not because the games are not
good right but because to me they are
not Assassin's Creed games as a guy who
loves stuff I'm the gaming ninja I want
to I want to Merc you in the dark I want
to you know what I'm saying like I don't
want this fistic cuff straight up battle
face to face and then you know like
that's not Assassin's Creed to me I grew
up with this Assassin's Creed we going
we going to go through the crowd we're
going to do the environmental stuff
we're going to get the information and
we are not the best fighter straight up
right it is not to my advantage to take
people head on because that goes against
the stealth ethos and I get it don't get
me wrong the new formula I understand I
am in the minority and they it is way
more popular now and they have evolved
other systems that blow the old stool
stuff away I'm never going to take that
away but it just sucked that it was just
going so far away from stealth for me
that I was just out I was like I'm not
in it so when I heard about Mirage and I
heard about this this plan to kind of
Call of Duty the series where you like
to me you know what it is like the new
version is like the Modern Warfare guys
in Call of Duty the old version is I'm a
Black Ops Assassin's Creed like I'm this
is the Assassin's Creed so if they even
making a Black Ops for me granted I get
what you're saying s like it's clear
like they probably was so scared they
like just give them the old tape for
btim don't change nothing give them the
old joint no new features they they
can't get mad cuz we gave them the old
we give them no that's what they wanted
and I think to your point maybe they B
was a little bit too extreme and went
too verbatim verse for verse for the old
stuff and now it's like okay we got you
you can now include a little bit of more
modern sensibilities with the stealth
and and and and and up that up a little
bit and as long is they keep making them
that's all I want just you got Mirage
yes I want Cog wants 10 shoes yes yes
absolutely
absolutely know what I'm saying you guys
they're bringing back they're bringing
back Splinter Cell talk to that team
about what they're doing that's what I
want like I'm I'm not into you know 200
hours and ion map vomit all over my
Assassin Creed I'm not into that like I
want specific targets I want to learn
about why we killing them and and to me
it's more realistic that you can't take
on seven guys and doing all this other
stuff that's not assassin you got to be
I don't understand how like first off
the reason that people have that mindset
is because Assassin's Creed they build
you up as an RPG character so you can do
stuff like that in an RPG to that degree
but at the origins of Assassin's Creed
is literally you are fragile they put
you in those scenarios because you can
get in and get out without see anyone
seeing you no I agree I agree yeah bosim
bosim is a thief that's that is what he
is he is not a fighter he's not a
fighter and that's why at least I I
respect the attempt at this I'm not
saying this is perfect I'm not saying
yeah this definitely is better than all
the newer assassin's I'm just saying
this is Assassin's greed style that I
like now they just got to improve on it
and just make some more please just make
some more and I don't mind 12 to 15 hour
experience as as long as you tell a good
story now I am hearing the controversy
shout out to Tai from Longet shout out
to Mr mpls who they did say the the
issue that have with this is that as you
go longer there's certain scenarios they
put it where it's almost impossible and
the game forces you to do combat and
that that's when their combat really
gets exposed because the game is forcing
you to do combat right so at that point
you know fair enough criticism taken and
then um I Heard the ending his little I
don't know yeah what I heard is like if
for anybody again I'm not spoiler but
bosim as introduced in in balla yeah um
is a pretty important character and it
stands to be an important character for
AC lore in general right so um this is
his origin story right so from what I
heard yeah it was like the the ending
doesn't hearken to what happens to
inalla enough where it makes it an
interesting connection so yeah yeah no
that's that's pretty much all I got on
it so yeah again I'm just happy for the
attempt I do want to move on cuz I got
to respect Colts time just want to know
how you un quote if you got we got you
for the red fall how how much time we
got you for I I I got to talk about the
red fall before I leave yeah all no
doubt no doubt harby Super Chat super
chats are crazy no we got a couple real
quick get this I want we got Alvin $2
Super Chat Chargers kind of like a
Mustang stares into ma in MA America
America America say America
America then we got PK Thunder whoa $5
Super Chat once again FYI Starfield did
not start slow for me at all what is
going on
here
what it started kind of quick for me
like I don't know was it slow me because
they throw you into the mix pretty quick
um then we got family Lord valon Super
Chat man I can't wait for Mirage and
having wow come to Xbox will be huge so
I mean look we hope we hope we got to
see how the integration is you know what
I'm saying but we shout out to S valon
OG cadow five members the crew you know
I'm BX represent you already know sure
then we have Spectre bull $5 Super Chat
could not stand balla as an sc newbie
but Mirage has my full attention it may
actually encourage me to boot up Etso
collection yes Etso listen I love
Cassandra that is my second heart but
Etso Alor da that is the man Cody s
agrees Cody s agrees that's a tough
choice between Cassandra and iio they're
both Stellar characters exactly my
friends like dealer and zacher were
playing as
lexio and so mad we never let it up on
him man you picked the worst character
like Cassandra Supreme Cassandra Supreme
dude night and day night and day I gotta
say um and I don't often check the Lord
especially in the Cycles when I'm at
church while you guys
are we get when you're giving the shout
out to the uh to the chat uh I gotta I
gotta make a little speech let's go
let's go these people these friends of
ours they're on I go to other podcasts
I'm watching other people's podcasts I
get to guest on them or I'm on my show
and a lot of almost all these people
they're there they're at all the shows
they're just intrical you guys are all
I'm pointing at the chat right here off
camera you guys are so intrical to this
community privilege that we get to do
podcasts and talk the business and talk
the games and talk the ups and the downs
and you guys are all in all the same
chats you're like a mutual community and
we have to give you so much love for
being there and being together with your
friends in the chat it means a lot to us
as people who turn on a camera and go
and go gosh I hope people want to hear
us talk today I just big love to you
guys in the chat and I wish we could
just name every name n well they move as
a unit that's move as a unit now that's
love we we wouldn't be who we are
without them right so for sure
absolutely so one last one oh we got put
the crest in the chat for KJ Wars 885
remember for four months Lord gold thank
you appreciate it no doubt you already
know so we this is the last one bonus I
grab this s yeah red fall red Fall's in
the news very
surprising you know what I mean shout
out to Clover I was before I saw his
tweet and obviously but arcade Austin
huge update now available drop this week
60fps performance mode on Xbox series XS
stealth takedowns added increased open
world enemy population and new
encounters new controller settings
gameplay and combat changes and so much
more so this was definitely a surprise
it hit the webs so uh Colt Eastwood uh
We've SE to have experience with this
title both of us in it's early iteration
is a lot of controversy a lot of talk
and um obviously you know I wish uh
Paris was here did mention it you know
this was kind of uh what it kind of
preceded one of the um what preceded
this was one of the kind of the famous
interviews with Phil on on kind of funny
and talking about you know obviously the
stay of the redfall was a big big
discussion at the time in the community
so what are your thoughts redfall now
with an
update um cor
Arcane zipping their lips while they got
this update all already like they would
put the like about once a week or every
two weeks they would put out like some
little like hey remember red fall is
here or you know Lea can do this or
whatever and they would get roasted in
the replies where's the update why
aren't you speaking up where's 60 FPS
why didn't the game Run on Console
properly and they put their heads down
and they just got this ready and they
just dropped it on
a I don't know Friday or whatever it was
I think it was a Friday and um yeah that
had to be so rough for them and some of
it you know it comes with the territory
when you can't get you know when you
when you're a bit bit underbaked but um
I I have no reason to replay it I have
like almost 100 hours into it but I wow
yeah I mean I have like 60 some hours
but Xbox says I have a 100 uh but I
played a lot of it on P most of it on PC
The Experience yeah I remember the PC
experience we see it versus console
yeah uh I played it a lot mostly on PC
because of uh because of that and it
even didn't hold 60 properly on PC so
for me and I have a 3080 you know it was
just like well digit founder explained
it just you it had problems so I loaded
it up on the console and it looked kind
of like a PC version and then I'm
looking there and there's a field of
view slider goes all the way up to 120 I
think which is really surprising like
not only do you get to 60 but they're
going to let you push it even harder uh
at 60 and then it has dead zone changes
which were big complaints for people
first person shooters and they
absolutely did add more enemy encounters
I I I can't walk past two houses without
seeing a new group of enemies and that
was not the case correct you had to walk
an entire block with nothing to do so
that's a fact shout out to them man yeah
yeah shout out to them now now here's
the question I got for you co we got to
really get into the Weeds now you know
obviously we're all surprised by this we
didn't see see this one coming but I
don't know if you caught um Pete hines's
comments maybe earlier um in the year
and he was kind of talking about how
obviously they knew they didn't hit you
know the targets what they wanted to do
with with redfall and you know he was
very animate the 60 frames per second
power is coming but he also was kind of
like we expect this to be around and he
he he used the term Fallout
76 now I don't know if you saw the steam
numbers in the increase of what's going
on but
you know is it do you feel it's
realistic possible the steam numbers for
redfall you mean we saw that is that
what you were talking about the the
three the grand you know total of steeve
guys but I guess but I really want to
get into the steam par it's kind of
funny but those three people with Arcane
probably on Steam testing the testing
the what touch that but sorry go no you
good that was funny we're having fun we
having fun we having fun but the
question is you know the the the
comments is you know he is looking at it
like a full out 76 situation kind of
redemption so do you think red full if
they keep could turn around or it's like
look bro we we appreciate what you you
did but it might be time to move on
where where you at with the long term of
redf yeah I'm I actually have an answer
you probably wouldn't expect I would
rather I was saying like a couple weeks
for this patch that that Arcane should
get to 60 FPS push out those new
characters and just walk away but what
Pete Hines was saying which people
always misquote him since he said the 10
year thing was he said you have to
remember this game in 10 years is going
to be sitting on Game Pass and it can't
sit on Game Pass in in its current state
right is what he's saying so he's like
good point Arcane needs to get the game
to where it should be because someday in
10 years he says someone's going to load
this up on Game Pass and say what's
redfall and it needs to be in a good
place now Fallout 76 took three years to
get where it should be but I hated that
game now I love it yeah so they did I
feel so weird sitting in the seat like
I'm like sitting in a
little
um um yeah I mean Arcane needs to like
they need to work
on Dishonored three or whatever they're
making and they need to make that
amazing so they just need to set us set
aside a small team it's going to be
mostly on support on heavy support for
team yeah yeah for the redfall and get
everything up to up to speed and um
there I don't know I mean you can make
big they made big changes to Fallout but
what redfall needs is their mechanics
that they put in the open world but they
only did them one out of three times or
one out of three um like my best example
is there's a cultist radio tower that
you go up and you blow it up and and and
knock it down and then that's it there's
a cop car in the second map which most
people don't even know there's the
solely second map in the halfway point
of the game there's a cop car you go
over and you hit the broadcast and it
starts a one through five wave of
cultists and vampires that you have to
stay off and it's really cool and I'm
like and you do it once you can never
reenact it it's not a thing that they
placed here or there in the open world
I'm like why that's really great so if
they can do that maybe they could make
the game better because it does have
those moments of uh this is a cool game
no definitely some potential some you
know in in the mix of all the madness
you know what I'm saying there's some
potential that you hopefully you know
they see they can realize see adct or
addict's back I just want to make sure
adct the 60 frames updates right for
back let's go right we ready it's all
the
way N I ain't there yet I I do respect
him the the fact that they did fund this
I mean it took them six months to do
this and to be honest with you I thought
it was just going to be that if you
would have sit there I don't know why my
camera's like that no you good if you
would have told me like six months ago
that they not only were going to do a 60
frame patch they were going to you know
fix a lot of the issues and criticisms
they've had in the world I would have
said you're delusional uh but you know
they're doing it it does seem like you
know Bethesda has took a lot of the
criticism to heart and you know they
they are fixing these issues and for the
people that are telling me that these
weren't issues or what now they fix they
were clearly issued it's like look what
now yeah clearly they they they fix them
there's issues and it's just like I like
that because you know some of that
Ubisoft energy you know we're not going
to put something out the The Ether if it
don't work out we're just going to
abandon it's like you know we promised
you a product might take us a minute and
that doesn't excuse the fact yes you
know I I'm on that same wave I was with
cyber punk you know except for the Cyber
Punk was a little bit different because
they were doing a little like some very
unusual things but when it comes to this
it's like look if you got Game Pass
you're willing to give another chance to
do it if you don't I don't blame you at
all fair because a lot of the times you
get that initial oppression you'll never
get that
again good point good point sa me and
you were had fortunate to cover this
game on
PC cover a similar game similar game on
PC but uh now that the dust is settled
on Console there is a patch an upd
stealth kill which was in your uh what
are your criticisms when we talked about
yeah so how we feeling redf is it safe I
don't know that it's safe um I haven't
again I I downloaded it again I haven't
booted it up but um just looking at kind
of the improvements obviously the 60 FPS
was something that H for a lot of people
was a big deal 60 FPS is great I think
people that played it at 30 didn't
really that that was the least of the
problems least of the issues game but
it's great that they did that because
the game again any shooter modern
shooter I'm going be honest man just
give me 60 FPS it's just smoother it's
what people should be playing any sort
of first person game at it's a 60 FPS
minimum um the other stuff that was kind
of more important I think to me because
that's it's an Arcane game right and and
it didn't have a lot of Arcane uh sort
of DNA in it and one of the big things
was the fact that when you sneak up on
people there was no sort of animation
for a stealth kill facts it was just you
sneak up behind them and shoot them in
the back of the head or whatever it was
it was nothing else yes and sometimes
they didn't turn around when you did it
sometimes they get mad yeah yeah exactly
just you know hit him with the with the
gun butt of the gun um so so the fact
that that's there is cool I I I'm hoping
that it's not one per character or it's
just they added one and they all have
the same one um but again it's it's good
that they went back and addressed these
sort of criticisms that people had of
the game um another the biggest one I
think that it kind of makes or breaks
the game is the AI stuff right yes um
and AI stuff and the density of the
world where the density of the world
that we played in that preview in that
vertical slice was it felt it felt alive
it felt alive in that it was it was it
populated with a bunch of dead things um
but it felt like everywhere you went um
there was some s some form of danger
that you could be in um whether it was
cultist whether it was uh one of those
vampire mini bosses sort of holding down
a specific area um there was always
something or there was something in the
realm of story beats where you would you
know enter a space something happened
there and like you could you know the
environmental storytelling would tell
you kind of what what happened there and
then you could you know you could jump
off of that so uh I I I'm anxious to see
what they did with that right because
they did say they they improved the
density of the game in on the in the
console space um and I'm hopefully the
the PC is well so I'm excited to see if
that is true because that is kind of
where the the game just did not feel
like there was any sort of synergy
between the world that they created and
then the gamepl they created to to sort
of function within that World um and
then on top of that the idea of synergy
when you talk about this game I think
one of the things we talked about was
the fact that hey if you put all of the
powers together from all of these
characters you get one corvo from maybe
maybe maybe um so the hope is
that and it being mostly a multiplayer
game right the hope Hope was that the
the powers of each of these individual
characters synergized in a way that made
the game play fun when when taking on
these enemies right and none of that
sort of came to pass in the final game
so my hope is that they continue to
improve in that regard was like hey
whatever whatever the or at least
address it even if they roll it back and
turn it into something else and be like
okay how can we arcany this this even
more and forget about the Synergy
between the characters because it's too
difficult well then give the car each
character more sort of su sort of uh
immersive Sim to style moves yes so they
can function they can all be sort of
unique within this world but they but
they all have a plethora of tools that
they can attack the preach not just oh
the same ability but you get a little
bit more faster recharge on the same
thing I agree more deeper into the Ste
exactly cuz to me this is it if you're
going back you're continuing to work
this on this game I commend that I I'm
so grateful and happy that they're doing
that because this idea is cool this idea
was always cool
especially with Arcane behind it it just
the game that came that they released is
not doesn't have Arcane DNA it really
doesn't it's very little there so arcany
the game and really put the work in to
do that yes and make it a better product
I'm not expecting it to to have a No
Man's sky turn around right or a cyber
punk you know Phantom Liberty turn
around going to do okay I'm I'm hopeful
I'm not expecting it but hey who knows
but the thing about it is that the core
game here the core the core game they
released ain't that great right so they
would have to rework the whole thing
we've seen it we we've seen it right
because they they went back to the
drawing board on cyberp Punk and gave us
you know at its core it kind of
functions differently so it's it's a
possibility I just don't know that
that's what they they're willing to do
on this title but if they are do it go
all the way and let's not have the final
word on this game be oh they went back
and sort of addressed some issues but it
still sucks I mean but what to CPK what
if what if from a resource standpoint
doing that prevents you let's say oh no
go to this out of
three you don't want you don't want the
cyberpunk than you for the 60 FPS thank
you so much let's go to you want red
fall Phantom Liberty you know
what I'm good homie I'm good there's a
big difference cyber Punk and I'll say
this controversial thing let's go cyber
Punk was always a great game and
replaying it right now in the opening S
I mean the opening quarter of the game
so not really any new content it really
reaffirms that cyberpunk was always a
really great game and is worth redeeming
redfall is worth fixing yes why we gotta
stop why we can't why we can't had a
comeback story y don't want to see that
y don't want to see on a little bit
listen if if if it can be done without
removing resources from the next project
yes yes whatever that may be sure 100%
I'm all in and I will be there to
support uh if that is not the case if
that is not the case and said new
project happens to be Dishonored 3 yes
or a new IPO whatever it may be that is
very much in arcane's wheelhouse what we
expect from them we going to let Harvey
do what he want to do we let Harvey do
what he want do let's move on all right
all right all right you know I guess
look man I
agree why we can't why decid to can't be
all hold and we get comes between you
know giving redf fall less resources and
trying to fix uh trying to fix I mean
giving dis uh dishonor three resources
and trying to fix redfall uh redfall had
its
opportunity this Honor doesn't need to
to have less of an a less of a potential
to thrive it's like look I get it you
know they they gave us a a 60 frames and
I didn't think that was gonna happen to
a degree so it's just like to me we
already in the W range like let let's
take this small w we have and let's
let's ride off into the sunset sof you
try to stop me from getting my Harvey
interview part two that was a highlight
of my life always it isn't always what
fans like a a segment of fans want
because we know that the Arcane team
really wants to move forward and if that
is Dishonored 3 like that's what they
all really want to do and so if they
segment um a 10% of the team to do
control and repair and delivering the
promise of what redfall is uh in the
next year or so that's fine but if the
team is passionate about Dishonored 3
sometimes you put out a game that isn't
amazing yeah every team even Insomniac
has put out Insomniac has put out Banger
after banger but fuse was not a great
game I think it's like a 65 Metacritic
it you know nobody ended up playing this
four-player Co-op cover shooter it just
didn't land and what did Insomniac do
they moved forward and they did a small
game and then they put out sunet
overdrive so you got to let him cook let
him cook all right so that's my closing
statement I got to go I got to eat
something
awesome love the Lords and I feel like
we were we were just there we were just
like
hugging like not only do you have to let
them cook like you got to give you know
just because
redfall wasn't the success that you know
I'm sure some people had Xbox and
Bethesda wanted to be at the start it's
like that doesn't mean the studio can't
do anything good it's like you know
sometimes you got to give that second
opportunity to learn from your mistakes
cuz what I don't like is stuff like
cisto protocol not getting a sequel
because like even though I wasn't the
biggest fan of that game I feel like the
majority games deserve a sequel to
correct mistakes they made from the
prequel and it's like I feel like most
times we could have had a franchise but
some some dude named Allen that works at
one of these big Executives he decided
that it wasn't worth investing into damn
and and now they're a support Studio
doing something like fair fair enough I
want to get Co
out of here on top Co East with more
than gameplay working to find people
find you what else you got going on
before you leave sir uh I'm just gonna
be playing some Forza and I'm uh
absolutely loving my cyberpunk replay
and then I'll move on to Mirage and uh
we we will cry we will whine we will
complain but we are up to here in
amazing game so let people be excited
let people be hyped about what they want
to play let people enjoy the game you
don't love uh Hey I'm going to play
games you don't love so uh just have a
good time out there and uh I appreciate
you guys andate brother that you bring
together much love Co appreciate you
brother always a pleasure to see get
back and get get your drive on you know
what I'm saying and hopefully I see you
s always pleasure the legendary Lord
coat Eastwood in the building salute
enjoy your Sunday brother thank you guys
see you yeah already know yeah for me
I'll just make it quick um I'm a little
disappointed y a want me to interview
Harvey again you know what I'm saying
cuz I was I was trying to have my moment
you can ask him about the new
thing look just for the record that red
for interview with Harvey is our number
one video now you know it bro it is our
number one video right now that that
couch has sold thousands of thousands of
that couch has sold so many here's the
thing though is that our number one
interview for good reasons listen they I
think people really like my reporting
with let St all jokes aside look I get
it you know what I'm saying I I do think
it's interesting you know look Pete had
said you know they they they had a
long-term plan and you know they're not
going to give up give up on it you know
the question would be like you said the
extent is it just to not give up to fix
it to get it to a playable State the
functional State and then kind of move
on with just a you know live service
live maintenance team or is it a
full-fledged we are revamping and doing
kind of what maybe solve suggested if
they were going to do which is skill
trees all that other stuff um you know
my issue look I played this the the
patch 60 frame yes thank you thank you
yes it looks good it moves good I I love
the stealth kill option you know I still
got issue though I mean I still saw the
popping on Console was a little a little
rough you know what I'm saying also with
the um the mobs you know the the AI is
better but I still still couple of
instances with certain mods weren't
reacting to other emerging events so I
was like all right still a ways to go
there you know what sucks is the permise
of the game in Vampire is so cool and
you just want it to succeed but there
could be a point when it's like hey get
it to a point of playable playable State
maybe that's where they stop it at and
then they move on you know to the other
you know the the majority team moves on
to the big project I am curious though
if they truly commit to fixing that
would be very interesting I want not
that I would be mad it would just be
interesting to me you know if they did
it so um look one thing about live
service you know if you put enough
effort it could come back but we'll see
you know me P personally I'm with you
guys I rather at DIS on three at this
point you know what I'm saying I rather
them give the fans you know what they
truly want and have a team that's really
dedicated cuz by understanding with
redfall is remember internally the
reports came out that some of the team
they wanted they was hoping this get
canceled and and there was summon a team
that was thinking they was going to make
a classic arcade game then they left
saying hey we didn't really kind of sign
up for that and I'm very curious to see
what Harvey once you know what I'm
saying that that's that's why I would
love the interview again because it just
like hey what do you want to do and if
he's afforded a team to make another
game in his vision why you
laughing because it's funny you know you
know obviously he had to do this right
but in that interview you know he's all
in on this on is F it's fitting and it's
like obviously you know again you're not
going to you're not going to Crater your
product before it comes out right you
have you have to support it and you
can't you know you can't do a shoot
interview
like right right before it comes out
like this thing is worst don't buy it
facts facts facts you can't but it's
it's GNA be interesting to see you know
what what the pivot is right yeah you
know yeah we'll see we'll see again but
more importantly shout out to Arcade for
keeping their word on the patch because
at the end of the day I'mma be real I
thought it was going to be spooky and
they was going cuz it's been a minute
and I was like wait a minute that was
supposed to call oh they might be trying
to sweep this under the rug and act like
they ain't say cuz they did promise it
so salute to the team for doing that did
you see um the thing IGN got themselves
into yeah I saw that I saw that yeah did
you see that song no I missed it what
happened what they do so they they
promoted
a tweet talking I guess it was an
article I don't know if it they made it
recently or maybe it's an article they
made previously and they were just
promoting it on Twitter if it's an
article they just made and then they
promoting it but this article said with
no thir 60 frames uh with no 60 frames
patch no road map or something else I'm
sure the verbiage people someone in the
chat can give me it says I think it's I
think it's safe to say that like red
Fall's dead or something like that and
then like 10 minutes later they
announced the 60 frames wow age like
like milk right yeah that that age well
they were getting druged through the the
the streets of Twitter yeah look I'm
just happy that they were able to
command it was more than just the 60 it
was also you know quality of life stuff
so salute to them for keeping their word
that that's my main thing cuz they I was
a little worried like yo we here from
this we this patch coming and they would
just move on but now they did that so
look it is what it is hopefully they
turn it around if not give us this H3
thank you anyway that's all I got uh
Super Chat sir we get pulling up out of
here yes sir okay oh you got it no I get
super chats uh let me see Spartan 661
remember for two months with Browns ah I
missed the whole show I'll watch after
it's over all of you are awesome I'm in
the white mounds of New Hampshire
working see you guys later damn go go I
I've been I've been in the White
Mountains in New Hampshire yeah be safe
bro be safe do you think then we got Pat
F member for two months Lord bronze
great to see Colt on ILP another great
week in the round absolute thank you
much love then we got Homeless Bird $5
Super Chat this honor 3 would be
incredible as a huge fan of Arcane I
want to see another prey and an FPS
boosted version of Dishonored too yes no
fpf boost on on that on Console yeah
facts and here's to a better future yes
salute we got pragmatic Eagle $5 Super
Chat I just want to know if they fix the
pow the powers with Booty Juice they
have not fixed poers did they fix those
if not still no point to play the game
for me I get it fair enough fair enough
it's kind of what I was alluding to and
then Alvin with the $5 Super Chat Leon
is probably already working on this
honor three we saw the leaks Austin will
be on something different redfall work
doesn't affect dishonor we just true
about no he's right he's right Leon is
dead yeah is the dishonor Deb right so
the worry with with Austin
is how many how many people that know
how to make an Arcane game quote un
quote are still there um and will they
have the ability to staff up and and go
back to making an Arcane Style game so
you're absolutely right it is Theon yeah
it's Theon making dishonor and Austin
well with Austin what I would hope is
just that if Harvey gets his vision to
make the classic G this is the man from
what's it prey DX like if he's able to
make his vision of a game a new IP and
get a team that's obviously wants to do
that in in Kat that to me is super
exciting and I would love for that
studio to get a Redemption story you
think he's leaving you think he out hary
got the bag he out yeah I think um you
know he's not came out openly with his
plans but I think it involves him
leaving all right well we see well wish
should the best if he do and if you
don't get back to business and do we
know you to do this is because again on
that game in defense
backbox like that game was
pre-acquisition and remember the inside
of rumors was they were hoping it got
canceled because they didn't really want
to go into that but that's they try to
catch the live service multiplayer wave
initiative you know what I'm saying then
when Phil went over to visit he he he
didn't he didn't go into that room yeah
yeah clearly clearly clearly he went
down the hall cuz I remember the the
documents kind of implied room and said
where's the Starfield they CAU fly that
they thought that it was going to be
good so you know it's a lesson learn for
Xbox you know when you acquire you got
to make sure see how those older you
know projects are he's been very
transparent about the misstep there so
any so super chat still sirry that is it
all right cool let's get the poll with
the latest rumors of Naughty Dogs
factions multiplayer being on ice what
do you think is the best course of
action moving forward choices are a if
the core gameplay Loop is not good
Bungie's negative review is Justified to
cancel factions B Sony should give
naughy dog more time to refine factions
for review C allow naughty dog to make
an entirely new multiplayer Vision with
Bungie support or D I don't care but we
going to flip if we keep getting
remasters The Last of Us signal player
games shout out to all those in the chat
it will go up later today again shout
out to Paris Lily shout out to Colt
Eastwood holding us down in the absence
of the king send King some love he had
some appointments he could not get get
out of but he did want to bless the
realm with his opinions hopefully y'all
like that and his uh
VR I don't even know what he was doing I
don't even know what to call that cyborg
King I don't know what he was doing but
shout out to him for the laughs and
again holding us down in the interim
Lord adct where can I find people find
you what you got going on you can find
me on Twitter Lord addict IOP uh you can
find me on YouTube at G gaming addict I
will be having a video going live
tomorrow going to be uh you know these
people won't socialize themselves with
it but that's
fine damn you talking about there's
people in the chat that's gonna love it
but you it's you know I've been I've
been all my exposing the truth Triumph
that here recently so uh tomorrow is
another chapter of uh add exposing the
truth so definitely go over to my
YouTube channel gaming addict to it's
pretty much done I just have to do a
little bit more minor editing
and I will be probably posting it around
noonish tomorrow but uh I think I'm
gonna upset people then I'm not going to
upset people but I upset people all the
time so we be good on that so we get a
preview of what the the subject is we
got to wait nah we G to wait we we going
wait have someone snatch my video I 24
hours I'll feel that uh so yeah right
there click on that go go sub and uh
watch watch the salt tomorrow man watch
the salt tomorrow appreciate we we had
almost 900 people in the chat uh you
know very good show looks like we're
going to end the show Almost 5,500 oh
wow views there's still 631 people and
525 likes I know we can get up that man
before we leave I'm I'mma send you guys
to let's see who we going
today there's no one that see you have
to excuse me because Cog follows people
on the IOP Channel I don't it's between
legendary
jobs jpg and Shan K the king okay all
right all right and the Turk The Young
Turks which they have a bunch of people
we're not sitting you there so it's
between legendary drops who are these
people called who should I them to out
of those three um we said legendary
drops who was the second one uh Jade
PG and sea K the king all three decent
you know just tell me which one
legendary man let's do legendary let's
do that send send you guys a legendary
drops go over there and put in IOP Rays
when you get over there no doubt Lord s
where can find people find you what you
got going on Sir uh hopefully playing
Mirage and some way say or form I'm
excited to to play more of this I
haven't played one of these in a long
time and I and I got ready for it by by
playing a little bit of U of Brotherhood
but brotherhood on the PC is weird
because
Brotherhood every time you shut down it
crashes the whole thing breaks yeah yeah
yeah P Master racist it looks nice while
you're playing it it runs nice shutting
it down is the problem another day but
yeah it got me ready for this so I'm
excited to get back in there and uh play
more of bim's origin story so hopefully
I do more of that and uh yeah yeah
that's it uh what else we got we got a a
month coming man we got Spider-Man
around the corner Allan Wake I forgot
what it got pushed you but I what I'm
very excited for so yeah look out for
that stuff no doubt and of course again
appreciate the love appreciate y'all
coming through having fun s we will be
covering
Spider-Man uh I saw people asking did we
get codes in the chat uh Playstation
never really messed with us to that
degree but we will be covering it after
it comes out no doubt got get that on so
yeah next Sund she be good um again send
some love to the king doing his thing
deserv it break and fun show and stuff
that he's doing send some love he is
okay we just mess with he hates when I
say send some love the funny thing is we
always say king is responsible for the
link to the show because of his tangents
we're going hours I I I feel like when
King's not here we like we could speak
more
we shout out to King on that and again
everybody that K through par is with the
love you know what I'm saying of course
C Eastwood and yeah hopefully we'll see
what happens should be potential news
next week maybe we'll see if if the that
news happens we yeah we we may have to
alter and do things but yes Griff we
will hold the last and then the
following week will be our Spider-Man
Impressions yes no doubt but that's all
I got everybody enjoy your Sunday
anything else before we roll up adct NOP
we are good all right we good we out of
here everybody enjoy Sunday
peace
bills2 $2 super trap from Nintendo Don
the otaku you better cover Super Mario
Wonder two we actually Reach Out Cog is
on that
you is our Nintendo
Representatives he gets all the Nintendo
Co Pokemon he is our definitive Nintendo
guy Lord addict it it won't be the the
week it comes out uh but I will no it's
just I we gota wait for the game to come
out but it will probably be it comes out
the day of Spider-Man as well so oh yeah
it release it didn't release then it
didn't release all right so it will be
most when we talk about Spider-Man I'll
probably try to play both of them as
much as possible I do want to indepth on
U the RPG one the Mario RPG coming out
at the end of the month I think so this
the one with the mushrooms or not this
which one no this is the this is the one
with the new mushroom room get high
Mario I think Mario RPG is November if
and I and I asked for a couple codes so
we can all play and they ain't push it
back cuz it came on Spider-Man date Push
It N You Know M Mario
a't Mario's out selling Spider Man oh
yeah oh Mario is out selling big Mario
outside okay that Mario is gonna sell 10
million in two days over Spidey with the
to with the ven well there ain't nothing
else to play on the switch so
damn there something there's something
about 2D Mario bro just think just think
about uh or uh the all these games has
come out Starfield Assassin's Creed
Mirage Resident Evil 4 ain't none of
that on the
switch I mean they do got tears of the
kingdom and this GI yeah and it's been a
couple months so I'm sure they they they
they feeding the tube man they they they
they they want a little bit more anyway
so you heard it here first Nintendo um
Lord adct got you on Super Mario Jor got
you and now we
[Music]
out
is